This is Jocko podcast number
38 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay,
we're foot slog,
slog,
slog, slog, and over Africa. Foot, foot,
foot, foot, slogging over Africa,
boots, boots, boots, boots. Yeah.
Moving up and down again.
There's no discharge in the war.
Six, seven, 11 five,
nine and 20 mile today for
11 1732 the day before,
boots, boots, boots, boots,
moving up and down again.
There's no discharge in the war.
Don't, don't, don't, don't
look at what's in front of you.
Boots, boots, boots, boots.
Moving up and down again.
Men, men, men, men.
Men will go mad with watching them
and there's no discharge in the war.
Try, try, try, try to think
of something different.
Oh my God.
Keep me from him.
Go in. Lunatic boots, boots, boots, boots.
Moving up and down again.
There's no discharge in the war.
Count, count, count, count
the bullets in the bandoliers.
If your eyes drop,
they will get on top of you.
Boots, boots, boots, boots,
moving up and down again.
There is no discharge in the war.
We can stick out hunger,
thirst, and wariness,
but not, not, not, not
the chronic side of them.
Boats, boats, boats, boats,
moving up and down again and
there's no discharge in the wall.
Tanked so bad by day because a company,
but knight brings long strings
of 40,000 million boots,
boots, boots, boots,
moving up and down again.
There's no discharge in the war.
I have marched six weeks
and Helen said a Phi,
it's not fire devils dark or anything,
but boots,
boots, boots, boots,
moving up and down again and
there's no discharge in the wall.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
That's a poem.
That's a poem
called infantry columns by Kipling.
Rudyard Kipling.
Okay.
Who we've actually read before
on the podcast, he was a
British correspondent. He
was an author. He was a poet.
He was a patriot,
a British patriot,
and he was actually also critical of war
and paraphrased from a book
by a guy named David Gilmore.
The long recessional,
the imperial life of Richard Kipling.
Kipling was deeply critical of how
the war was fought. And by the way,
he's talking about world war one of how
the war was fought by the British army
as opposed to the war itself,
which is kind of like Hackworth.
Hackworth was more opposed to the
way we were fighting in Vietnam.
Then he was opposed to
the actual war itself.
Hm.
And he complained is early.
This is Kipling complaint as early as
October of 1914 that Germany should have
been defeated by now. Then something
must be wrong with the British army.
Kipling was shocked by the heavy losses
that the British expeditionary force had
taken by the autumn of 1914 and blame
the entire prewar generation of British
politicians who he had argued failed
to learn the lessons of the bu or war.
And as a result,
thousands and thousands of British
soldiers were paying with their lives
for failures in the fields.
And so there's some definite complexities
to Kipling and it actually goes a
little bit further and deeper
with these complexities.
And there's a reason I
started off with that poem.
Yeah.
And that poem,
it is
pretty much attributed that that
the, the, the ID of that poem,
which is obviously about marching long
distances and it's attributed to a series
of forced marches that were
led by in the Boer war,
which were led by Field Marshal,
Lord Frederick Roberts,
who led 60,000 men on forced marches
during the second bu or war in South
Africa. He let these forced marches
that were almost a thousand miles,
950 miles from Cape Down to Transvaal.
Okay.
And so that's kind of weird.
This,
this poem comes from about how maddening
it is to march in how hard it is.
But the interesting, the other interesting
piece of this is that Lord Robert,
Rob,
Lord Roberts,
who led this March was actually
personal friends with Kipling.
They were,
they were close friends and
Lord Roberts was commander in chief
of the army during World War One.
And at Kipling's request at root,
your Kipling's request,
Lord Roberts allowed Kipling's son to
be admitted to join the Irish guard.
He had some kind of a health problem.
And so Kipling Rudyard Kipling
called him up and said, hey,
my son's got a health issue,
but he needs to get in the game.
And Lord Roberts worked it out,
you know,
commander in chief of the army and got
him, had him admitted to the Irish guards.
It was actually his eyesight.
He had poor eyesight.
And so the,
okay,
the horrible piece I guess of that is
that, as I mentioned the first time
we read a Kipling poem on here
is that Rudyard Kipling son.
Yeah,
John Kipling was killed in September
of 1915 at the battle of loos where the
bro,
the British suffered 60,000 casualties
in three weeks of fighting's 60,000
casualties.
His body was never identified
and he is one of the 20,000
British dead that are corrupt,
commemorated by the Lou's memorial.
And while his body was never found,
there were accounts
that he was last seen slogging through
the mud blindly after a violent shell
explosion had ripped off his face.
And there's further connections.
And one of the lines in the poem is
that there's no discharge in the war.
Then this is actually from the Bible.
ECCLESIASTES,
Ds eight eight says there is no man that
hath power over the spirit to retain
the spirit.
Neither half he power in the day of death
and there is no discharge in that war.
So what he's saying there is
no man have powers to power over the
spirit to retain spirit. Meaning you,
you can't keep your soul when it's,
when it's time for your soul to go.
You can't keep it.
And then neither half the
power over the day of death.
Obviously you have no
power to overcome death
and there is no discharge in that war.
And that is that this ultimate struggle.
Yeah,
between life and death.
That war that we fight for life itself,
there's no escape.
Yeah,
you can't get out of it.
There is no discharge from that war
and
[inaudible] maybe a little
heavy way to start the podcast,
but that poem also has a special meaning
to a certain group of people in the
navy. And those of you that know
what I'm talking about there,
you know what I'm talking about there.
And it's a poem
that I thought of often in my career,
especially when I strapped on my gear
and heave dawn overloaded ruck sack for a
long patrol or march.
And when you do that,
any soldier, a military man will
tell you this, that when you do that,
that is one of the most demanding
parts of the job. The ruck March,
the long patrol, the hump, a little walk,
the forest road march. And even
though you're with a group of people,
when you do that,
when you're marching,
you're very much alone.
You're alone with your
thoughts and there's things
that you got to think about.
You've got to think
about your field of fire.
You got to think about your navigation,
you've got to think about rally point.
You've got to think about head count,
you gotta think about terrain feature.
You've got to think about the enemy and
booby traps and ids and all that stuff.
But even with that,
there's still a lot of empty
space to fill up inside your head.
And I recently
took my kids out on patrol and I
guess to be grammatically correct,
it was a hike in the civilian world,
but in my mind it was a patrol.
It felt like a patrol
and you know, it's
the same thing. I mean essentially
you're moving from point a to point B.
You said security. When you get
there, you set your layup point,
which civilians call like a campsite.
Then you sleep and then you wake
up and then you do it again.
And as I did that patrol,
and since it had been a while since I
had done a patrol and because I was also
watching my kids on their first patrol.
Yeah,
I got to kind of revisit my
little relationship that I
have with patrolling over
the years.
And
also as I saw them suffer and
learn through their first patrol,
I got to thinking to everything that I'd
learned over the years from patrolling.
And in doing that I realized how
much patrolling had Tommy. So I'm,
I'm there, I'm walking and I'm thinking
about all these things that I learned.
Because again, when you're
patrolling, you got time.
Even if even if you're thinking about
navigation, you're thinking about
all these things,
it doesn't matter.
Even every piece of the job that
you're focused on, it doesn't matter.
There's still space to fill. And
that's what happened. My, you know,
your mind starts to think about all
these things and it dawned on me how much
patrolling and marching had taught me
in and how it's really a fundamental
component in everything that I did
in the seal teams in the military.
Okay.
And like leadership,
there's some fundamental principles that
apply universally to so many things in
life. And also just like leadership.
There's a certain aspect of patrolling
in navigation that is as much art as it
is science.
And the science of course
is relatively easy to teach,
but the art
as always,
the art is hard to teach.
And finally with this,
this idea of navigation of
moving from point a to point B,
which includes plotting a course and
picking way points along the way and
identifying it and avoiding obstacles
in route and how to overcome the
unexpected obstacles and how and when
and where to rest. And everything else.
That navigation at patrolling includes
and all those things are things that you
face as you navigate a life.
And as you set goals,
as you establish
where you're going.
So I wanted to take a closer look at
land navigation and how it relates to
leadership and life. And
in digging in, I looked at,
I looked at some of the
information out there, some of the,
some of the field manuals and
yeah,
it's,
it's
okay.
I learned from people, right.
And I didn't learn from a book.
And as I winter to the books,
I was coping that I could find what
I had learned from people. But,
but I didn't really find it.
I found pieces of it,
glimpses of it,
but nothing like what I was taught by the
guys that raised me in the seal teams.
And you know, I looked up the
uh, Army FM three tech 25. Dot.
Two six map reading and land navigation.
It's a thorough document and it's very
heavily heavy on the scientific side,
but the actual technical skill of it,
like how to set declination at a compass
and how to work at the map and under
what the contour line.
All the basic tools are in there.
And there's some good quotes and
one of the quotes it said today,
the complexities of tactical operations
and deployment of troops are such that
it is essential for all soldiers to be
able to read and interpret their maps in
order to move quickly and
effectively on the battlefield. Okay?
Can't argue with that.
You got
to know where you are.
And if you ever heard me say this,
I always used to ask the uh, the
young, the young seal officers,
what's the most important piece of
information you need on the battlefield?
And they would say where the bad guys
are or how many guys you have or how many
enemy there are or, or anything like that.
They'd have a bunch of different ideas.
And I would say, no, no, no, no, no.
The most important piece of information
you can have on the battlefield is aware
you are, you got to know where you
are otherwise nothing else matters.
And then I looked at a book
called the last hundred yards,
which we actually covered on this podcast,
podcast number three.
And it goes through a
section which is describing,
is talking about gps and
how now we've got gps is,
and the GPS is can be unreliable and you
can't count on them and all this stuff.
And it's kind of true. It was even
more true when that book came out,
which was in 1995 and there
was less satellites in the
sky and the gps receivers
weren't as good. And the encryption
methodology wasn't so dialed in yet.
So the GPS is,
we're less accurate back then.
And they were also still pretty big.
They were these big contraptions.
And even in 1993 1994 the GPS is
that I carried or big heavy things.
Basically you had to assign
a person to carry them.
And now of course they're tiny.
They're, you know, everybody's got, um,
you know what gps and you're on your
iPhone or whatever smartphone you're using
that are a thousand times better than
the one I used to carry on my back.
And they're also very accurate and
reliable. Now in the military's comed up,
rely heavily on them,
perhaps perhaps a little too much.
And I'm not going to be a guy that's
like a stick in the mud that says, hey,
don't evolve,
don't learn anything because technology
is awesome and you have to take
advantage of it.
But I also do think there's a
need to remember the old ways.
And I remember when gps first came out
and I was coming into the seal team and
they had this thing and I remember this,
this officer's would,
this officer's particular
said to me, you know, hey,
all I need to do is see all we need to
do is carry this thing and, and you know,
we'll know exactly where we are at all
times. Then he hands me this, you know,
20 pound brick but big box
thing and are kind of said,
hey man,
all I need to do is carry this map and
compass and I'll know exactly where I am
at all times. It's called land
navigation. I want to learn it.
But nowadays, uh, the GPS is,
are awesome and we definitely
rely heavily on them. But,
but it is,
it is piece of the last hundred yards
that definitely emphasizes that you have
to know how to Land Nav,
which is good.
But like I said,
when I looked through these books,
none of them gave me this same clear
level of instruction that I learned about
land navigation. It patrolling
when I first got into the teams
back in the day.
And again,
these instructions in this methodology
and some of these basic principles of
patrolling and Land Nav,
they stuck with me and are
really fundamental building
blocks of how I ended up
doing everything that I do.
And they're really the basis
of the attitude that I had
that was very beneficial
and leading me to having success
in other areas, which was awesome.
And so again,
here I am and taking my kids on their
first patrol that made me realize this so
clearly. And as I was thinking
about, I was like, you know,
I'm going to talk about
this on the podcast.
Okay.
Because these are lessons that I learned
that I actually forgot that I learned.
You know what I mean?
These are lessons that are so embedded
that I forgot that I thought about them,
but I think about them all the time
and then not seeing my kids do this.
I'm thinking, Oh yeah, there they are.
They're learning this right
now for the first time. And so
to go through some of those things,
some of those principles,
the first one is planning and you know,
we, we, this gets every,
of course everyone knows you've
got to come up with a plan,
but doing a detailed map
study and identifying the
obstacles that you're going
to have to get around.
And there's a couple different methods
that you can use for land navigation.
One of them is called dead reckoning.
And dead reckoning means you get a compass
bearing from point a to point B is,
you know you're going to be
traveling on 270 degrees.
So you put your compost on 270 degrees
and you march, you go in a straight line,
don't let anything take you off that line,
head down and go.
And that's called dead reckoning.
And that's obviously can
be very problematic because
if in between you and where
you're going is a giant mountain or a,
you know, a bunch of rivers or whatever,
you're gonna have to go through all
those things and you're going to get,
you're going to get worn out,
you'd get tired.
It might be not tactically
advisable to go through those areas.
And so the better form is called
terrain Navar Terrain Association.
And when you're doing that,
you actually look at the
map and you study what the,
what the ground is going to do.
And so if there's a big mountain,
you can skirt around the bottom of the
mountain and then you get to have the
side of the mountain and there's a,
a ravine that's,
you can follow that ravine around till
you get to a certain point on the ravine
where it cuts far to
the north and you can,
you can head in the other direction to
your, towards your turn. So it's this,
it's a method of really
knowing the terrain that
you're going to be on and it's
infinitely more effective
than dead reckoning.
So if you think about this
from a perspective of you
have a mission that trying
to get done well, how are you
going to get there? You know,
how are you going to
get this mission done?
Are you going to just put your head down
and absorb any impact that you take and
apply more pressure or
you're going to be smart?
Are you going to study the terrain and
take a look and figure out the best way
around those obstacles,
those
dead reckoning and terrain association
util the Terrain Association.
You don't like,
let's say,
go around the mountain and then tried to
get back on the dead reckoning course.
You're just using the journeys,
the terrain,
and you'll know when
you do your map study,
you'll know that you're going to
go skirt around this mountain.
You're going to go down a ravine,
then you're going to cut
over by this open field.
You're going to hold along the wood lines.
When you get to the end of the woodline,
there's going to be a fence.
You're going to step over that fence.
Once you get to the offense,
you're going to fall the
fence for, you know, uh,
until you hit another big terrain
feature like another hill,
and then you're gonna fall off the base
of that hill until you get to a stream.
So you're going to know exactly
where you're going the whole time.
And you can imagine how
much more effective this is.
I mean you don't have
to look at your compass,
you are taking advantage or you're going
to patrol in areas where you have a
tactical advantage too. So it's just uh,
a much, much better way to do things.
So a lot of times I think
people, um, you know,
they hear the big uh,
the big navy seal like, oh,
we're just going to get it done.
You just stay on the course,
right?
Well staying on the course means
I'm going to reach my objective.
It doesn't mean I'm going to pound my
head into the wall without thinking.
Right?
So that's what terrain
features do for you.
And there's also some terrain
features that are interesting.
You can use reference points that keep
you from going too far so you can know,
hey, if we hit this main highway, we went
too far. We know we missed our target,
we missed our turn. If we hit this
river, we know we went too far.
If we hit this ridge line,
we know we hit went too far.
So you're going to set those up for you
and they're going to confirm where you
are. And also you're going to
use those as reference points,
so you're going to tell you a whole team,
so your whole team is going to know,
hey, we made it this far. Oh there's the
big river that were turning left at. Okay,
we turned left and that's awesome. Next
they're going to hit is a Woodbine, oh,
here's the woodline so everybody knows.
And so imagine if you're,
again,
think about this outside
the the parameters of land
navigation and patrolling.
Think of it in a regular business or any
situation where we're trying to get a
team to do something.
If you lay out the course for them and
you plot out what the obstacles are and
you explained to people where they're
going to be and how how important it is
that they need to get there and
what we need to be looking out for.
I imagine how the team feels,
the team knows where they,
they understand where they are when you're
doing dead reckoning. The back of the,
the guys in the back, they have no idea
where they are. I've been that guy.
I've been that guy in the back of the
patrol and you just have no idea where you
are. You have no idea how much further
to go. You just got your head down,
your your slug slugging along with
your weight and it's a nightmare.
Whereas I've been on good
patrols where I'm in the back,
but we got a really good brief and I'm
like, oh, there's that mountain own,
there's that ravine. Okay, we should
becoming that stream soon. Oh yes,
we're at the stream.
So you know where you are.
And when you provide your team with
that kind of clarity on the course that
you're planning to take,
it's going to make them so much
more aware of what's happening.
And the more aware they
are of what's happening,
the better performance you're
gonna get from him. Yeah.
The other thing is,
as you're doing this,
you do something called a pace
count, which is your, as you walk,
you know how many paces it takes you to
get a hundred yards and there's some, uh,
Kentucky windage is there as walks and we
were going uphill or downhill. You can,
you can work out these diff,
what you can get pretty accurate.
So you can know that, hey, when I take
left, when my left foot hits the ground,
on average,
when I'm wearing a hundred pounds,
it's 86 paces for me and I just went
a hundred yards. So that's, that's,
you'll know that.
And so then what you're doing is you're
constantly checking it gives you another,
it gives you another reference point
because if we're supposed to hit, uh,
you know,
a stream in 300 yards,
and I know we've marched 600 yards,
some happened right time for me to stop.
In fact, at 400 yards, I'm
probably gonna stop and say, okay,
let's do a quick map study.
So you want to double check these things.
And in a business world,
this could be some kind of a timeline that
you've set up. So you're like, hey, at,
at, you know, 42 days, we should be here
on this project. Oh, we're not there yet.
Okay, what's the problem? What did we
miss? Why aren't we getting it done?
So that gives you two sort
of methodologies to confirm
where you are as you can
triangulate your position, which is
smart. What'd you call it? Kentucky. What?
Kentucky windage what does it mean it's
give or take? You know, it's just, uh,
it comes from shooting.
Oh, and you would normally,
you dial in your site
to get you specifically,
let's say you think 600 meters,
but then there's a strong wind blowing.
So maybe you're going to hold off to
the left to the Queen d in Kentucky or
something I think is just shooting the,
maybe the shooters in Kentucky had a,
they made it their real accurate
pulling a little Kentucky when we got to
accommodate for that. Yeah.
Gotcha. Chicago windage no,
no. Well cause it's kind of
windy, you know, so yeah,
I see where you're coming from,
but no, it's, it's, it's Kentucky.
Windage my broaching you.
So
like I said, in life plan study,
the route that you're going to go,
think about the obstacles.
How are you going to avoid him,
what your goals look like? What do your
smaller goals look like along the way?
The little reference points. So you've
got somebody you signs with a big project,
okay,
what are the little things?
Or you got something in your life
that you're trying to accomplish.
What are the little goals
you've got to set for yourself?
So you get to keep a reference point
along the way and what's the timeline
you're going to eat those on?
Yup. That's how you stay on track.
And you know what we actually did?
We did something called pacenotes
and what pacenotes were,
and I learned it for for foot patrols and
we ended up using it even more when it
came to vehicle patrols. And I,
I realized that, I don't know,
maybe 10 years ago or something,
we started sending guys to a rally driving
school so I could learn how to drive
rally racing cars.
And that's day.
That's been the way they always done
pacenotes in rally racing. So you,
so what's cool about it
is when you do pacenotes,
you're writing down specifically,
this is the terrain feature,
this is what I'm seeing.
This is how far away it is.
This is the next terrain feature.
This is what I'm going to see
and this is how far away it is.
So you can actually track that.
Now we got so detailed with that on,
on vehicle mounted patrols,
we would actually just take the map and
blow the map up so we'd see exactly what
it looked like at that intersection or
at that juncture at that city blocks.
So we could see what the buildings
look like. So we'd be looking for,
so that's pacenotes and it, and it,
it's almost like a rehearsal, you know,
it's almost like a
rehearsal cause you can,
you can walk the whole team through and
they can get a visualization of what
they're going to see and how, how
it's going to look. And the other,
the other piece is that I said is you
got to share that plan and explain it to
everybody. So everybody's on the
same sheet. And, and I did this,
w I x explained it to my kids,
you know, and I said, okay,
here's what we're going to see.
We're at this area here,
we're going to go across some flack round,
we're gonna start hitting some
little terrain features here.
It's going to go up and
down and up and down.
That's going to tell us that we're here
and not only does it help them know
what's going on,
but now I'm talking through it and
that helps me because it helps to teach
things because when you teach something,
you become more proficient at it.
That's one of the good things
about teaching anything.
You know you want to get better at
something, teach people how to do it.
It makes you better.
You want to teach that arm lock or you
want to get better at the arm lock,
teach the arm lock. You'll notice
all kinds of little details about it.
It's so hard to teach,
like if you're not used to teaching,
I jump in there and t cause you're just
used to doing it and a lot of that stuff
you just do without thinking about, okay,
what exactly am I doing? This detail.
You just do it.
You don't muscle memory.
And there's all these little factors
that facilitate you doing something that
you don't even think about and then
tried teaching. You're like, oh,
you kind of do this. Wait,
wait, Whoa, whoa. You know,
you didn't even know what you're saying.
You know,
Greg train always throws
out little details like, oh,
that's a good little right and
he has something that I do.
But once he points it out or teaches it
and he'll be teaching us something basic
that I know and I'm good
at. And he'll say, oh yeah,
and then I put my foot on the hip here
to stabilize this. And I go, I go,
I do that. When you start
thinking about a new focus on it,
it makes you that much better at it.
And it's the same thing that's going to
happen here when you actually brief your
team and tell them exactly what to expect.
Now again,
this doesn't mean that
you're going to say, hey,
this is what exactly how it's going to go.
Cause you've got to give the caveat that,
hey,
this is our plan and where you might
have to deviate from this plan and that's
okay, we're ready to do that, where
adaptive. But when you talk through it,
it helps you and it helps
them. Yeah, that's funny.
Greg train is the reason I ran into him.
He was like,
he's teaching or whatever and then he
just all of a sudden busts out, hey echo,
teach them that move that you do.
And I was pretty good at that move.
I started teaching.
I think it's like,
it is a guard past that I do
sometimes and Brown, I'm teaching it.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I'm like doing it all good but,
and everyone's like, oh, all
right. You know, I was like
Brown, I am a poor teacher.
Well that's something you can work on.
I guess starting now,
take over the podcast.
I'm more comfortable avoiding it.
Awesome. Uh, now that,
now the next piece that I was thinking
about on patrolling and that I saw my
kids go through and that I went through
as a young seal is you start questioning
or you start going through this process
of what do I need to bring with me?
What do I actually need to bring with
me? Now, when you don't have to carry it,
well, when you don't know what it means
to carry it, carry it. When I say Carrie,
I mean put it on your back and
bear the weight of that item.
When you don't have to do that,
you want to carry everything.
I'll just carry everything. That warm
sleeping bag in the whisper lights,
stove and the extra food and the
comfort gear and all this stuff.
That's what you do when you,
when you don't have to carry it on,
you don't think about carrying on or you
don't know what it feels like to carry
it,
but when you have to carry it,
you get down to what you need real quick
to what you actually need real quick.
Totally limited on the food.
You're not going to be,
I never, I never heated a meal in
the field unless it was like, um,
snow on the ground,
a winter warfare scenario,
never heated a meal in the
ground if it was never,
never heated a meal because that means
you had to bring a fuel and a whisper
light and all this stuff. And
I never, I was a radium side.
I already carry a radio and
then I got used to that.
So by the time I was an officer and I
wasn't carrying a radio anymore, I said,
I'm just going to be lighter than
everybody else. Yeah. Um, comfort gear.
No, no, we won't take that. And
do you need to,
do you need to get it,
you need to bring enough comfort here
that you can actually sleep and survive
and be, you need to bring a ground
pad or whatever. Um, but you know,
we used to say a little sang was
travel light freeze at night. That,
that was my same for sure. Travel
life reasoning. And I'll tell you,
I got my indoctrination to freezing
at night and traveling light.
When I first checked into the team,
I went to a comm school communication
school, a seal communication school.
So you're going to learn
how to be a radio man in the
seal teams.
And I had this,
this old chief that
was run in the running,
the running the training and
I was a fired up new guide,
even have my tried it.
So I was just brand new guy,
didn't even try knows at the team
and they sent me to the school.
And so this chief and I actually
went with another new guy who's,
who's a great guy and we went
out there total new guys.
Neither one of us had to try it.
So we had graduated from buds a couple
months ago or from airborne school,
whatever.
So we showed up,
it's wintertime and we show up and the
end of this school you go through uh,
a field training exercise and it's,
I want to say it's five days in the field.
It's like Monday through Friday in the
field or something along those lines.
And you are basically doing
the reconnaissance mission
and they give you really
good targets to look at and you're going
to look at and you're going to report
back with all this information
and then you're going to move,
they're going to move
you every couple hours.
They give you directions to
a new point to move to. So
we're doing where we're getting ready for
this FTX and I'd never spent much time
in the field and the guy that's
running the course, you know,
he's having fun with the new guy and he's
like, hey Welink. And I said, yes chief.
And he goes, you know what you
think your hardcore, and I go,
I'm trying to be hardcore. And he
says, if you're really hardcore,
you don't need a paunch, you don't
need a sleeping bag or a ground pad,
you'd just go out there with a, with a
Poncho and Poncho liner. And I was like,
okay, no problem. So sure enough,
I go in the field with a Poncho and a
Poncho liner and actually I actually,
it was a bivy sack, which is a Gortex.
It's like a Goretex sleeping bag.
Just a thin gortex shell
and a Poncho liner,
which is something that's been around
forever and it's just a very thin,
thin blanket. No, it's not even
a tent. It's like a blanket.
It's like a blanket. That's what
it is. It's a very thin, it's, yes,
it's a very thin liner. It's
what? It's the Poncho liner.
And so I had, those are the two
things I had with me and uh,
and my buddy took the
same so we were like, oh,
oh that you need to be like that to be
hardcore. I'm article or how cold was it?
Like,
so we are going into the field,
we're inserting in the field and in the
sun is going like we've inserted right
at dusk as we're inserting in the field,
it's raining right as we get on
the ground at turns to sleet.
And then two hours into the
night it turns into snow.
So we freeze. I mean
we freeze, we're just,
we can't sleep.
And the funny thing was
was that we couldn't sleep.
We literally couldn't sleep.
It was too cold for us asleep.
And you and the guy had set it up. So
you had to make a communications window.
You had to make communications.
It was about every three or four hours.
And so, and if you missed a
communications window, if you missed it,
that was, you know, you
got your grade went down
or whatever, you got
points subtracted. Hmm.
So all the other guys who were experienced
seals that knew how to live out in
the field better than we did,
they all were super comfortable.
They all went out there and had sleeping
bags and ground pads and all that.
And they slept through their calm windows.
At least some of them,
they didn't sleep through all of them,
obviously.
But occasionally it sleeps through one
after four days, three days, whatever.
And so we were the only pair that made
all of our comm windows cause we couldn't
say good. You know? Yeah. We'd just
be standing up just standing up,
standing by a tree, doing burpees,
just trying to survive. Yeah.
So that was,
um,
that was one of the lessons
on our learning how to
travel light freeze at night.
Now that we're a little too
much. I I should, you did,
the thing I needed was a ground pad.
You need to ground pad when you go in the
field. So travel late, freeze at night.
It's kind of like a warning or is
that like no it's a deal to do.
It was my methodology and it's,
it's the methodology of a PR,
a portion of guys in the military
that are, that are on the,
it would rather be on the hard
side. Right. So I'm going to,
I'll freeze that night so I can travel,
travel light freeze at night because
you're going to be more effective when
you're, when you're lighter. Yeah. I
mean of course if you're exhausted.
So that's why, that's why
there's gotta be a balance there.
We should have brought ground pads on
that operation to that and that training
operation for sure.
Yeah.
And and like we got trench foot legit
and the guy that was with me had legit
trench fort when he got out.
Like no,
it's when your feet cause cause this old
part of this op part of this training
operation took place in,
in like a swamp.
So says freezing in the swamp and he got
legit World War One style trench foot.
I had it to my,
not as bad as him but what is that?
It's just your feet get numb
and rotted and jacked up.
Yeah. Good Times. So, so again,
how do we apply this to life
and I, and I think if you,
if you look at what you want versus what
you actually need and imagine if you
had to carry everything that you owned.
Now of course that's not possible.
But I think this is this whole
like minimalist attitude that's,
that's kind of getting popular right
now that it's getting popular in the
civilian world right now. But in the
military we've always valued that.
And it's one of the cool things
about going away on deployment. They,
for me, I always love this feeling
when you went away on deployment,
you can only take w we as as
seals took a lot of gear with us.
But there's a limit. You took, you
know, five or six kit bags, you know,
five or six big duffel bags basically
filled with gear and that's it.
That's it. That's all your gear.
It's all the gear you have.
And so honestly to me that,
that always felt good.
That is what I got. This is
everything I have. And you know,
as a young seal that was basically you
could fit all your gear in those six bags
and then everything you
owned in the civilian world,
you could fit in two more
bags. And we live that. Like,
I live like that with my
buddies back in the day.
We live like that for a long time. Oh
you, we can go on an appointment tomorrow.
We just put all of our
stuff at home and a kit bag.
We can blow in our stuff up and
we can be ready to go. Yeah.
Kind of like we're the uh,
military guys are Kinda like the
old g minimalists back in the day.
Good. And then we got, I got to
teach Sarah this stuff. Yeah.
When people start to hold on to stuff,
especially the part where
if you or when you carry it,
you realize how much you know that part
where you're talking about once you know
the weight of your own stuff,
you think twice before in is really,
really thorough.
Start thinking about the cost of that
gear and what does that mean over time and
how much of usage are you
going to get out of it.
Now the thing that I hang on to,
there's a couple things that I'm
a little bit of a hoarder on.
One of them is t shirts.
Yeah. I'm not mad at them now.
Now some people might be thinking,
Hey Jocko,
you wear the same freaking teacher
every single day. Which is true.
But I have,
you know,
old tee shirts that are
just, I just, I just,
cause I wear my tee shirts
a lot when I wear them.
It's hard for me to part with
them better that than shoot.
I have a,
I have a ton of old Jujitsu tee shirts
from like when I used to go to schools,
I used to traveling school.
Yeah.
And they'd give me a tee shirt and I
have all these old school teachers of
schools that don't even exist. Aura
schools that got really big or whatever,
or just competitions that I did.
You know,
when you've got those old school t shirts
and I'm not, I don't wear them anymore,
but I was thinking, you know,
what I can do is inventory them,
take pictures of them and put them on
the inner webs and then throw them away.
What do be, oh, like a, like a, like an
archive. Because, because there's some it,
it triggers memories that
are like memorabilia really
hard because you like to,
uh, it, it triggers the
memory of those times of the,
of that event or whatever cause
otherwise you're not thinking about it.
And there was a problem with that.
I'll tell you,
I realize this from my experience,
uh, grown up, you know, I grew up in,
in New England and I don't go home,
didn't go home at all.
It hardly ever go back to
the town where I grew up.
And the people that I
know that are still there,
they remember all this stuff
from when we were kids.
They remember this event and that,
and remember when this happened.
And I honestly don't remember.
I just don't remember it.
And I think the reason is because I go,
went away from there
and it never went back.
And so I have nothing triggering
triggering those members.
I don't see the school yard where
the fight happened. I don't see the,
I don't see the, the road where the
car flipped. I don't see that stuff.
And so I don't remember it like they do,
they, they're their old time. Oh yeah.
I remember when little Johnny
you get, you know, it's like, no,
I actually don't remember that.
So with some of this memorabilia,
as you called it, sure. If every
time I look at it I go, oh yeah,
that was cool tournament or that was cool
training with those guys or whatever.
So I have a bunch of Jujitsu tee shirts
that I have a hard time getting a bar
party with.
I was standing up taking them to the
gym and framing them and hang them up to
acoustics. No notch. I was teaching for
a year, but they're old school t shirts.
They'd be cool to have those old kids.
And if you, if you got my t shirts,
Dean tee shirts and Jeff Glover's
tee shirts and put them up in there,
that'd be sick. Yeah. Or it's on the
poster. I remember best of the West.
Remember that tournament? Yeah.
That was a good one. God. Yeah man.
So
that's it.
You go through this checklist back to
the subject here you go through this
checklist of what you actually
need. And again, when you're,
when you're in a business you
got to look at what you, what,
what do you need to complete this
operation, what do you just want?
Cause it'd be nice to have and separate
those things. Separate those things.
You can actually put them in those
categories, you know, need, want,
nice to have. Right. And then
you go through, okay, let's call,
let's contract and what we need first.
And then we can see if there's anything
that we want. And then by the way,
if there's a nice to have, we
can throw in there. Okay fine.
But to go in there and just
buy everything on that list or,
or command everything on that list
cause you think you're going to need it.
No wrong answer, wrong roof.
And a lot of times people,
and of course I'm not talking about,
well maybe plays or it does apply
to business, but just in life,
what you need and what you want.
You know,
lot of times what you want doesn't even
facilitate what you need. You know,
how like you'd be like, Oh hey, I,
I, I don't need faster internet,
but I kind of want it. But the faster
Internet is going to facilitate my work.
Well it's that you do, you know, you need
the internet at least that something,
sometimes people will get stuff that
they want that's just straight up no
function. Yeah. Oh yeah, for
sure. Well not in my family.
I know
things about function.
I know like him don't like him. Um, okay.
So, so again, back to this,
once you've decided on what you're going
to bring or what you're going to need,
then it's time to start the operation,
right? It's time to start this movement.
And even from the start you've got
to check, confirm where you are,
make sure you know,
then you get started.
And I had this first reminder when I
did this little patrol with my kids,
cause I just said, oh we're good to go.
It's a little trail and start walking.
We started walking. I didn't keep
a pace count. That's ridiculous.
That's embarrassing to them.
It didn't keep a pace count and
it wasn't really paying attention.
And we're just kind of talking and having,
yeah we're just talking and moving and
kind of getting used to it all. And Hey,
how's your backpack for you? And all
that stuff. And all of a sudden I go,
wait a second, where are
we? Where are we right now?
Cause I had told them that, hey, we're
gonna be looking for this trail goes up.
And we talked through it and we pulled
out the map and we started doing this
study. And my son was like immediately
with all we went too far, we missed it.
I know what it's back there, and my
daughter wouldn't commit either way.
And I said, okay, let's do
an assessment in. So we,
and realize that we actually hadn't gone
quite far enough so we went a little
bit further. But my point is
that you got to check yourself.
You got to check yourself and
check your team consistently.
Not Constantly, right?
That's micromanagement,
but consistently and you also have
to watch out for target fixation,
which is trying to go too fast.
I go,
you're just trying to get to that to the
end point without going by your little
way points along the way.
That is a way to get yourself lost
because you're driving and you don't,
you're not looking for your reference
points and you'll lose the bubble.
So you got to detach a little bit and
stand back and pay attention to not be all
crazy about that. You know for,
you know, every 500 meters,
maybe every you do a quick check.
Every thousand meters you're going to
do a little bit of more accurate study.
Okay.
And that's gonna keep you,
keep you in line.
And if you are not aligned, you only
going to be a little bit off track.
You're not going to be 12 days of work
or two hours of walking off track.
Yeah,
it makes perfect sense to specially we
by all these reference points that target
fixation, you're just, you've
got one reference point.
It's probably not even that accurate
because really just by the nature of the
whole deal,
the map,
the one reference point that you do have
is the furthest thing away, literally.
So you only have that one hour for that.
If you have all these other reference
points, you get off track one step,
two step, three steps. You still got like
a bond to reference points. He does all,
all right, let's backtrack all of
these reference points there to support
Geo. That's, that's how you
do it. And that's again,
that's when you're planning
something with a team and a business.
You got to have some reference points
along the way to help you get towards your
goal because your goal is far
off in the distance, you know?
So you've got a plan about
how you're going to get there
if you have a edit video or use
Photoshop or is it has this,
when I first started it has this history
little box.
Every move you make it records. It was,
that's pretty cool. Delete, delete.
And then you have control over it, which
is save. But that's something else.
But it, yeah, each one. So you
can literally go back, oh wait,
it's reference point with
every single move. That's
awesome. So you can go up, oh,
let me go all the way back. You know, 25
moves to when I erase this little thing.
Oop. And let me start
from there. You know,
you bring one thing back that's
far up the chart. Yeah. The,
here's the only thing it's like, but
it's like a little like a fork kind of.
So like let's say you go back in time,
essentially you go back like five moves
and then you make a different move.
It that one, this course. Yeah, it's
gone. That's why in time traveling. Yep,
exactly.
Time. Trial. All right. So
when you get out on patrol now,
um, disciplines paramount.
Sure. For instance,
you got to stay hydrated.
You've got to keep track of your gear,
you've got to keep of your pace count.
You don't let your gear get out.
You don't take out your gear like,
oh were stopped for seconds.
I'm just gonna pull everything out of my
rucksack and lay it all over the place.
No,
you got to keep it tight.
You don't rush over obstacles.
So for instance, Oh, you know,
it was a little log and I got us,
there's a log going across this
trail and I got to step over the log.
Well I step up on top of it and then
I'm just going to jump off cause I,
it's a little easier.
No,
you don't just jump off cause
that's how you sprain your ankle.
That's how you blow out a
knee, which is, you know what,
you're playing a basketball
game or you're on the Jujitsu,
Matt and you and you twist your
ankle. Cool. We'll walk to the side,
but some ice on it, you're, you know,
10 kilometers out in the middle of
nowhere and one of your kids sprains and
ankle urine, you're in trouble.
You have a, you're in trouble.
And if you're out on patrol in a military
situation and you get somebody that
gets sprained ankle,
you're an even more significant trouble.
So you got to have the
discipline to slow down.
Slow is smooth, smooth is fast.
Watch your footing, watch for danger.
Watch your field of fire.
Pay attention to the first person that's
in front of you and the person that's
behind you. And that's how
you're doing new communications.
You got to keep your communication
up the whole time. So again,
you can go right to any business,
any project that everyone's working on.
It's all the same thing.
You got to be disciplined,
you got to keep track of things.
You gotta keep your communication going
between your team members by passing
whatever signals you've got to pass.
When you get to a layup point where when
you're going to actually stop and and
basically camp out. I hate saying
that because in the, in the,
in the seal teams it's derogatory to say,
oh yeah,
so you never want to have anybody
say that. So I wouldn't let my,
when I went on patrol with my kids I was
like, no, we're not camping limp point.
But so you guys are camping out.
No or not.
So w w when you get to a lay up
point where you're going to stop,
you don't just flop down and
turn into a pile of crap.
And this is true. Again,
with a business situation,
you reach one goal.
You don't just like flop down and say,
oh we did it high five a office party.
No you can,
you can order a pizza maybe,
but you're not ordering booze.
You know what I'm saying? You still
got stuff to do so you don't camp out.
You have to remain tackle.
You have to remain disciplined.
You have to quietly assume
your security position,
you got to then be quiet and make sure
you are as a loan as you think you are.
Then you got to pick out some landmarks.
Once you get to your little lamp point,
you gotta, you gotta make
that your home. You know,
you got to look at for
some landmarks or some
somewhere where you know where you are
and then you confirm your position.
You know, you take a
triangulation with your compass,
maybe even break out your gps, get a
little double confirmation. And then once
you've got everything set, then you
can take a little breather. Hmm.
But what you don't do is get to the
finish line and just flop down and uh,
we made it right. You never want
to do that. And the other piece,
this is something I've thought about a
lot while I was on this patrol with my,
with my two kids,
I went with two out of the four kids.
Okay.
When that, we kind of have a standard in
most militaries do this. You're going to,
when you're, when you're doing a patrol,
you're going to move for 50 minutes.
Mean you're going to walk for 15 minutes
and you're gonna rest for 10 then your
walk for 15 rest for 10 walk from
50 and that's kind of the standard.
And I can tell you that
if you aren't careful,
it can be hard to start up again and
you get tired legs and you get sore
shoulders and you get hunger and you get
thirsty and it's easy to let 10 minutes
turned into 15 minutes and turn it into
20 minutes and turn it into a half an
hour. That can happen very, very easily.
And this is the thing you got to remember
while you are arresting,
you are getting no closer to your target.
There is no progress that is being made.
And by the way,
the only person that is going to
move you toward that target is you.
Yeah.
You're the only person that's
gonna move you towards that target.
You're not going to get carried.
Their target's not going to move to you.
You are the only person that's
going to move to the target.
And if you don't move, you'll never get
there. And the faster you get there,
the better off you're going to be.
Now again,
this doesn't mean that you're simply
grinding yourself and your team into the
dirt.
There are rest periods involve there.
You have 10 minutes of rest of
you have 50 minutes of work.
So I'm not talking about
smashing your team, right?
But you absolutely do have to drive your
team because there will be no progress
in the comfort zone. There will
not in the inside the comfort zone,
there's no progress happening.
There's nothing happening.
And when you're patrolling
with a rucksack on,
it is not comfortable, is not
comfortable, it's not easy.
And that is one of the things.
That's why this discipline of keeping
moving and continuing to push the pace is
so powerful.
And that's the same thing with any goal.
Obviously,
the correlation here is that
any goal that you're going for,
you have to keep moving toward it.
You have to stay on the path.
Yeah.
Do you have to rest? Yes, but you have
to go, you have to go down that path
and that is another one of these
principles and all of these principles day
really apply to everything
that I did in my seal career,
regardless of what I was doing.
The same things, planning, well,
setting goals, knowing what they look
like, staying disciplined on everything,
on every type of mission, on every task,
every job. That is what I always did.
I didn't take it easy. Did I
rest? Sure, of course I arrested,
but did I cut corners?
Did I take the easy way?
Did I slack off?
No,
no, I did not. I held the line.
Now from a leadership perspective,
all this talk of marching and patrolling
made me think of a short story
called the beloved captain,
which I was recently introduced to by the
wife of one of the finest leaders I've
ever worked for.
A guy named General Sean McFarland,
who was the colonel at the time
who was commanding the one one a d,
the first brigade of the
First Armored Division,
otherwise known as the ready
first during the battle of Ramadi.
And I recently saw general mcfarlane's
a wife at a memorial event that we did
for the 10 year anniversary
of Mark Lee's death.
And she told me about this story.
Again,
it's called the beloved captain and it
lays out some fundamental leadership
principles.
And when the general's wife told me
that he kind of referred to this story
himself for guidance,
I figured maybe the kind
of guidance we can all use.
And the story is written by a guy named
Donald Hanky who served with the British
army in World War One,
the volunteer who enlisted
at age 29 despite having
served as an officer when he
was younger,
he enlisted
to go fight and eventually
regained his commission.
And in both as a enlisted guy,
as an and as an officer,
he fought on the front lines
and he wrote this story,
which is called,
as I said,
the beloved captain.
He came in the early days when we
were still at recruit drills under hot
September, son Tall, erect, smiling.
So we first saw him and so he to the end,
at the start he knew his
little of soldiering is we did.
He used to watch us being
drilled by the sergeant,
but his manner of watching was peculiar
to his own. He never looked bored.
He was learning just as much as we were.
In fact more,
he was learning his job and from the
first he saw that his job was more than to
give us the correct orders.
His job was to lead us,
so he watched and noted many
things and never found the time.
Hang on, heavy, heavy on his hands.
He watched our evolutions so as to
learn to learn the correct orders.
He watched for the
right manner of command,
the manner which secured the
most prompt response to an order,
and he watched every one of us for
our individual characteristics.
We were his men already.
He took an almost paternal interest in us.
He noted the men who tried hard,
but we're naturally slow and awkward.
He distinguished them from those
who were inattentive and board.
He marked down the keen and most
efficient among us. Most of all,
he studied those who were subject to moods
who are sulky one day and willing the
next. These were the ones
who were to turn the scale.
If he could get these on his side,
the battle would be one.
So here's this leader,
very important for him to learn about as
men and know his men and study his men.
We've heard this before,
back to the book for the first few days,
he just watched.
Then he started work.
He picked out some of the most awkward
ones and accompanied by a corporal,
marched them away by
themselves in generously.
He explained that he did
not know much himself yet,
but he thought that they might be on
my get on better if they drilled by
themselves a bit and
that if it helped the,
if he helped them and they helped him,
they would soon learn.
So there's some serious humility
going on there. He's like, Hey,
I don't know that much. You guys don't
know that much. Let's help each other.
Let's build a little team here.
His confidence was infectious.
He looked at them and they looked at him
and the men pulled themselves together
and determined to do their best,
so he formed relationships here.
Their best surprised themselves.
His patients was inexhaustible.
His simplicity could not
fail to be understood.
He's keeping things simple, so simple
that they could not fail to be understood.
His keenness and optimism
carried all with them.
Very soon the awkward squad
found themselves awkward,
no longer and after that they cease to
be a squad and went back to the platoon.
Then he started to drill the platoon with
sergeant standing by to point out his
mistakes.
Of course he made mistakes and when that
happened he never minded admitting it.
Some extreme ownership going on.
He would explain what mistakes
he had made and try again.
The result was that we began to take
almost as much interest and pride in his
progress as he did in ours.
We were his men and he was our leader.
We felt that he was a credit to us
and we resolve to be a credit to him.
There was a bond of mutual
confidence and affection between us,
which grew stronger and stronger.
As the months passed,
he had a smile for almost everyone,
but we thought he had a
different smile for us.
We looked for it and were never
disappointed on parade as long as we were
trying.
His smile encouraged us off parade.
If we passed him and saluted his eyes,
look straight into our own
and his smile greeted us.
It was a wonderful thing.
That smile of his,
it was something worth living for when
worth working for a bucked one up when
one was bored or tired,
it seemed to make one look at things
from a different point of view,
a finer point of view,
his point of view.
There was nothing feeble or weak about it.
It was not monotonous like
the smile of Sunny Jim.
It meant something.
It meant that we were his men and that
he was proud of us and sure that we were
going to do jolly well better
than any of the other platoons.
And it made us determine that we would
okay
when we failed him,
when he was disappointed in us,
he did not smile.
He did not rage or curse.
He just looked disappointed.
And that made us feel far more savage
with ourselves in any amount of swearing
would have done
point we've talked about on here many
times that guy that's yelling and
screaming, not getting respect, that
that has a lot to do. Also actually
probably everything to do also with,
remember who we were talking about. Um,
use the carrot and the stick, you know,
so that's basically, I mean, you know,
on top of the bond or it could be a sense
kind of the same thing where when they
look for that approval, which we
all do with our friends especially,
they're not looking to avoid him getting
mad. They're looking to make them happy.
See, because of that, you know how, how
that feels or how, how good that is.
So he doesn't have to get mad.
He just has to basically go to zero.
He doesn't have to go negative 10 on him.
Yeah. He goes to zero one there like,
Dang,
I bill, I'm gonna get back to
that. Yeah, that Tan. Yeah.
And it's just great language.
He just looked disappointed and that made
us feel far more savage with ourselves
in any amount of squaring would've done.
Yep.
And I had a boss like that one time
with our whole golden life was just to,
just to make,
make him look good and have them say,
give us a smile on their job.
And we were all fired up,
know back to the book.
He made us feel that we were
not playing the game with him.
This is if they messed up.
He made us feel that we were
not playing the game by him.
It was not what he said.
He was never very good at talking.
It was just how he looked and his look
of displeasure and disappointment was a
thing that we would do anything to avoid.
The fact was that he had won
his way into our affections.
We loved him and there isn't anything
stronger than love when all said and done.
He was humble too, if that is
the right word and I think it is.
No trouble of ours was too
small for him to attend to.
When we started route
marches for instance,
and our feet were blistered and
sore as they often were. At first,
you would have fought that. They were
his own feet from the trouble he took.
Of course,
after the march there was always an
inspection of feet that is routine,
but with him it was no mere routine.
He came into our rooms and if
anyone had a sore fit foot,
he would kneel down on the floor and look
at it as carefully as if he had been a
doctor.
Then he would prescribe and the remedies
were ready at hand being borne by the
sergeant.
If a blister had to be lanced,
you would very likely lance it himself
then in there so as to make sure there
was done with a clean needle and
that no dirt was allowed to get in.
There was no effication about this,
no striving after effect.
There was simply that he felt that our
feet were pretty important and that he
knew that we were pretty careless.
So he thought it best at the start
to see to the master himself.
Nevertheless,
there was an our rise,
something almost religious
about this care for our feet.
It seemed to have a touch of the Christ
about it and we loved and honored him
the more
literally getting down on his hands and
knees and caring for the feet of his men.
Okay. And you know, you can
imagine the leaders that would,
that would see this as being beneath them
and maybe even thinking in some way
that this would make them look bad.
Right. But you can see, obviously
he's comparing him to Jesus.
Hmm.
So I think it was a,
I think it had a good effect on the men.
Thanks.
We knew that we should lose him.
For one thing,
we knew that he would be promoted.
There was our great hope that some
day he would command the company also.
We knew that he would be killed.
He was so amazingly
unselfconscious for that reason.
We knew that he would
be absolutely fearless.
He would be so keen on the job in hand
and so anxious for as men that he would
forget about his own danger.
So it proved he was a captain.
When we went out to the front,
whenever there was a tiresome job
to be done, he was there in charge.
If ever there were a moment of danger,
he was on the spot.
If there were any particular part of
the line where the shells were falling
faster or the bombs dropping more thickly
than in other parts, he was in it.
It was not that he was conceited
and imagined himself indispensable.
It was just that he was so keen that the
men should do their best and act wordly
of the regiment.
He knew that fellows hated turning out
at night for fatigue when they were in
arrest camp.
He knew how tiresome the Long March there
and back and digging in the dark for
an unknown purpose war.
He knew that the fellows would
be inclined to grouse and Sherk.
So he thought that it was up to him to
go and show them that he thought it was a
job worth doing.
And the fact that he was there put a new
complexion on the matter all together,
no one would shirk if he was there.
No one would grumble so much either.
What was good enough for
him was good enough for us.
So you got to got to get
out there and you know,
I've told stories about picking
up brass and doing the taking.
The bad watch is all those things.
And this is a exact commentary about that.
Just because you're in a leadership
position doesn't mean you don't get to do
the hard stuff.
We don't have to do the art stuff.
It actually means you do the hard stuff.
But let's talking to jade
who days ago and you know,
he's the boss of his company and stuff.
Um,
and man, it pretty much every word
that's coming from that is like, man,
it's reminded me of this,
where
like this certain people in a group
that can do that, that can go and like,
you know, he'll, there'll wash
your sheets, then you don't leave.
You don't automatically have that respect.
In some cases
you'll have less respect if like,
sure.
Like they're kissing your butt and
they don't have anything to look up to,
you know, or, or you know,
these, these kinds of guys or
whatever. But the point is,
as the leader or the boss
or the dad or whatever,
like everyone in the group is, is
watching you. People are watching.
So if you're like, you can be
like, Hey, you can make 10, 20,
50 great moves and then,
but let's say he just kind of come in
late every day or something like that.
Or like you're anticipating or something.
Yeah, they're watching. So they're like,
okay, I see that. And they're
not being critical necessarily.
They're just watching, I'm sure. Yeah.
I mean he can go conscious or even
subconscious. It could be, yeah,
they could be getting critical. But man,
they're watching. So when you're like,
when if they see you slack off, they're
like, it's okay to slack off. Yeah.
All right. Okay, okay. That's what we're
doing. You're not eating, you know,
if you're from a leadership position,
you're slacking,
you're followers are going to slack.
There's no doubt about it.
And let there be no doubt.
Or You lose your temper.
Or even even if like you think no one's
paying attention, and he was like,
you know, your kid is cruising with
your whatever you're on the phone with,
I don't know, the cable guy and you
know how they schedule that, you know,
between these two and
you're mad or whatever.
I'd be there between 9:00 AM and 9:00
PM or 9:00 AM the next day or something
and you lose your temper on the cable guy
probably he's watching. I was like, oh,
okay. That's kind of how it
is. Like that's how we do
it kind of thing. You know?
I'm happy for watching. So yeah, this
guy where he's doing the hard stuff,
you know, the, the top level stuff,
bottom line, he's doing it all.
People were watching it and they
see it, so they're like, man,
that's the way to roll.
That they didn't think were digging in
and move moving at night and digging in,
you know, for an unknown purpose. They,
he knew that they weren't fired up with.
Soon as he showed up and started
doing it, they all realize, okay,
it's good enough for him. You
know, that's how we're rolling.
It's good enough for us and
they're back to the book.
What was good enough for
him was good enough for us.
If it were not too much
trouble for him to turn out,
it was not too much trouble for us.
He knew to how trying the nerves,
how trying to the nerves it is to
sit in a trench and be shelled.
He knew what a temptation there is to
move a bit farther down the trench and
heard together and a bunch
at what seems the safest end.
He knew to the folly of doing it and that
there that it was not the thing to do,
not done in the best regiments.
So he went along to see that it did not
happen to see that the demand stuck to
their posts and conquered their nerves.
And as soon as we saw him,
we forgot our own anxiety. It
was move a bit further down, sir,
we are all right here,
but don't you go exposing yourself?
We didn't matter.
We knew it then.
We were just rank and
file bound to take risks.
The company would get
along all without us, but
the captain,
how was the company to get on without
him to see him was to catch his point of
view,
to forget our personal anxieties and
think only of the company and the regiment
and honor.
That's an interesting
concept is that you're,
this leader's presence actually opened
his troopers minds to what he saw.
Yup.
Okay.
That's awesome.
There was not one of us but
would gladly have died for him.
We longed for the chance to
show him that we weren't heroes.
We never dreamed about
getting the Victoria Cross.
But to save the captain,
we would have earned it 10 times over
and never have cared a button whether we
got it or not.
We never got the chance.
Worst luck.
It was all the other way.
We were holding some trenches,
which are about as
unhealthiest trenches could be
the bushes,
which is a slang term for the Germans.
The Bush's were only a few yards away
and we're well supplied with trench
mortars.
We hadn't got any at the time.
Bombs and air torpedoes were
dropping around us all day.
Of course the captain was there.
It seemed as if he could not keep away.
A torpedo fell into the trench
and buried some of our trap chops.
The fellows next to them
ran to dig them out.
Of course he was the first one,
then came another torpedo
in the same place.
That was the end,
but he lives
somehow he lives
and we who knew him do not forget.
We feel his eyes on us.
We still work for that
wonderful smile of his.
There are not many of
the old lot left now,
but I think those who went west have
seen him when they got to the other side.
I think they were met.
Someone said,
well done,
good and faithful servant.
And as they knelt before
that gracious pierced figure,
I reckon they saw nearby
the captain's smile.
Anyway,
in that faith,
let me die if death should come my way.
And so I think
shall I died content
and
die.
He did.
Donald Hanky who wrote that story was
badly wounded in the battle of Ypres on
July 30th, 1915 and after
recovering from those wounds,
he went back to the front,
including action at
the battle of the Somme
and later preparing to go over
the top at one 30 in the afternoon
on October 12th,
1916 lieutenant a Hanky was reported to
have told his men if wounded blighty,
if killed resurrection
in Blighty was a term that basically
meant million dollar wound,
which we've talked about before on this
podcast. The million dollar wound is,
hey, you get shot, it
gets you off the front,
but it doesn't kill you and
it doesn't maim you for life.
It's $1 million wouldn't. And that
day the Brits called that a blight.
And so at one 30 in the afternoon on
October 12th as his guys are getting ready
to go over the top,
he tells his men if wounded
blighty if killed resurrection.
So you boys have nothing to fear.
Shortly thereafter he was killed.
He is said to have been buried
near the spot where he fell,
although the grave was never found.
But we do have his words.
So let us heed those words as we tried
to lead others as well as he did as well
as we can,
as well as the beloved captain.
And with that,
it's been some time since we've done
some questions for the Internet so we can
move to those questions.
So sounds was good
after,
after hearing a story like that,
it's,
it's always tough for me to remember
that when you hear a one story like that,
you've got to remember that there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
stories like that
war and of leadership,
end of sacrifice.
And if we don't do our damnedest
to learn from those lessons,
yeah.
And apply them,
I questioned whether we even
deserve to have this life.
Yeah. That though about this,
this story, beloved captain.
Yes.
Like that's such a clear demonstration
on how to be, where these guys would,
would follow this guy basically into fire.
They could probably watch them walk
into a pit of fire and they'd all fall.
They did. Yeah. Think about it. They
did. That's what World War One was. Yeah.
Stand up. Go follow me. We're going.
Yeah.
So if this guy's mere presence can make
these other guys follow him like that in
these types of situations, like if more
people would be like this guy, you know,
in normal life, I mean it'd be a
breeze to have people you know,
listened to you and you
guys get some stuff done.
And,
and how much of the stuff that the beloved
captain does is counterintuitive of
what people think of a military guy.
I mean, almost everything in there,
he's admitting his mistakes.
He's figuring out who's
awkward at admitting to them
that he's kind of messed up
too.
He's getting down on his knees and,
and basically being almost submissive
to his men in order to make sure that
they're healthy.
He's taking all the hard jobs.
He's smiling and developing these
strong relationships with his men.
Like every one of those things is
almost counter to what people think. Uh,
um,
a big tough military is the jewel
Sargent drill Sargent leader like no.
And,
and so I see people in the civilian
sector that ended up in the same way they
think, they think that that's how you
lead because they've seen it in a movie,
you know,
that is not that,
that that hyper aggressive mentality is,
is ineffective with human beings.
And actually there's a question here,
so we'll probably talk about
that some more. Um, but,
but that's why I always make it
perfectly clear that I'm all about being
aggressive.
Yeah.
I'm all about being aggressive but
being aggressive towards your mission,
not towards people. I mean, unless
the person warrants aggressiveness,
which does happen from time to time,
that's called a fist fight.
You ended up part,
he noted where his mere presence kind of,
um, not imposed, but impacts impacts
their perspective where it's like,
it's basically him walking in to,
to whatever
the situation and them just
kind of automatically a
what what's he seeing right
there? So just coming
to them, hey, let me,
let me move this weapon cause
it's in a bad spot. Let me,
let me pull it up like that stuff up here.
That is completely right.
Completely right. I was on a ship one
time and I thought it was about the,
the commanding officer on a ship.
There's something called the one Mc,
which is a basically a loudspeaker that
goes throughout every portion of the
ship.
Everyone can hear it.
And this commanding officer gets on the
Sh gets on the one MC and he's going to
make a speech, right? Because that's
what commanding officers do sometimes.
And he says,
I thought he was going to make the most
epic speech because he's not the most
epic, but I thought he's
going to say something pretty
powerful. Sure. He says, um,
he says, Hey, when you, when, when,
when you see a piece of trash on the
ship and when I see a piece of trash,
I thought he was gonna say, when I see a
piece of trash, man, I go and pick it up.
And he said, he said something along
the lines of, when I see a preset trash,
I'm frustrated that nobody picked it up.
And think about the,
the impact of those two
statements. If he said, well,
I thought he was going
to say, which is, hey,
when I see a piece of trash on the floor,
I go over and I pick it up and,
and put it away or throw it away.
And then I make sure there's no the trash
near cause I want this ship to shine.
That's one thing. He, he said, hey,
when I see a piece of trash on the ship,
I get so frustrated that
you weren't cleaning it up.
And I was so let down at that ship that,
that commanding officers said that
at that shit. Uh, but to your point,
if you know,
it's like,
the reason I thought of that is because
you can see when even when I've been in,
you know,
the commander of a unit of some kind and
I would see when I walk in unexpected,
there's like a change, you know?
And it's not always, you know,
sometimes I've seen it where guys,
the commander walks in and it's,
people are doing that cause of fear.
Right? Right. Yeah. That's not different.
That's not what we're looking for. Or
You want to say, oh, the boss is here.
I don't want him to see that this
is going on. I don't know. This is,
we shouldn't be doing that. We
should. And that's, you're right.
That is a real powerful,
real powerful
fought that he puts in here about
how when when the boss comes around,
when the commander comes around and you,
and it actually provides the troopers
the ability to see what he's seeing and
how powerful that is. Wellington,
Jane, I forget what it,
he had to do the thing where it's like,
it was like a 10th thing and he was
just telling, I was telling him, oh,
he's talking to Sarah about it
and he's like, yeah, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna leave like right after that
cause I don't want to have to face like
some awkwardness or something like that.
And then, um, kind of once there I left,
I was like, Hey, I'm going to tell
Jocko that you're going to do that.
And he was like, all like, he knew I was
joking, but he was like, ah, you know,
Kinda like, what would you think about
that? You're not even as loss by the way,
obviously, but it's kind of
like that thing, you know,
like, Hey, whoa. Would like, um,
you ever watch, remember commando?
Yeah. It's not, yeah, go ahead.
There's this part right where the
story behind commando is one of his,
his guys that he trained and
stuff, um, went rogue, went back,
came back and they thought he was dead
and he comes back and he helps you know,
the, you know, great, great
story. It's dope. Anyway. Um,
so this, this bad guy
now he, you could stay,
you could tell he still has
all this admiration for,
for his name's John Matrix.
For Arnold. Yeah, for our
logo. Cause he's like,
he's walking around the compound
that he's kind of like, you know,
and all these guys are like talk,
talking to and stuff.
So he goes to the other boss that
he's now working with. Um, he's all,
it's, it's funny to hear your men
talk tough. It makes me laugh.
If Matrix was here, he'd laugh
too, you know, kind of like he's,
it's almost like human matrix are
on the same team still. You know,
he knows how he would see that. You know,
it's kind of that same thing. Presence.
Awesome. Uh, so
wrapping that rough transition,
people want to support the podcast.
How are they going to do it?
Echo Charles? Well, one way,
the way I like to recommend one of the
many is by supporting yourself at the
same time on it.
Supplements.
And where are your bars on a
dotcom slash Jack will get 10% off
before this podcast.
I'll make it short before the spot
gas and when I get a shroom tech,
I didn't get 10% off.
Not You can get 10% off.
Or if you shop at Amazon,
a click through our websites is
another way you can support podcasts.
A click through our websites,
Amazon, the link, our websites.
That's Jocko podcast.com and Jocko
store.com there's a little thing you can
click on. Yup. Yup.
And you can support that way cause it's
like thing it doesn't count. Does not,
it barely costs you time. Barely. Really?
The thing is remembering to go there.
Yeah.
So that's kind of the thing.
Oh, good solution to that.
Yes. Which we do have now.
Little trooper tool trooper
tool is what it's called. Uh,
it's this cool little thing and
it's on the website as well.
It's as a trooper tool,
chrome extension, boom,
click on it puts a little icon on the
top of your browser and it automatically
affiliates your Amazon experience with,
with US support passive roofers passively?
No.
Passively as opposed task deciliter.
No, no, no. It's aggressive. Yes.
But it's not. So yeah. All right.
Passive means you didn't do anything.
It's,
we have,
we have troopers out there that are
aggressively shopping on Amazon to support
the podcast. And I dig
that. I read that sometimes
my friends on Twitter,
they'll send me like a screen shot,
boom of their trooper tool or their,
or their little purchase. Like, Hey,
I bought this stuff tape, here's
my thing. And it's a screenshot.
Yeah. It really makes me feel
empowered and I'm not joking. Right.
It does help the podcast
fully appreciate it.
Fully subscribe to the
podcast of course iTunes.
And then on youtube as well.
I'm slowly putting more videos.
I'll put a few and keep putting more.
Oh,
so you're not just stuck watching the
podcast, which is cool too, by the way,
if you're into watching it and listening
is sometimes like people will put it on
their screen as they work out,
you know,
so they can kind of watch lists
and workout watch lists, you know,
it's a good little little formula anyway.
Yeah, youtube is a good one as well.
And of course the Jocko store if you like,
you know,
shirts and whatnot, coffee mugs,
stickers. Um, they're pretty cool.
I've got some great feedback.
One announcement.
We have women's stuff coming
out in about what week or two
female troopers.
Yup.
Who have been pressuring
strongly recommending will
say consistently strongly
are up recommending. Yup. Yeah, they're
good ones. Uh, I chose three colors.
You're going to have to wait and see
which ones they are and when they do come
out, give me more feedback. I
want to narrow it down to the,
the stuff that we all want. So
yeah, go ahead. Do that. Jocko.
store.com there's some cool
stuff. If you like it, boom.
Get one or two or however many.
And that supports as well.
And plus that means I don't have to buy
my wife anything. Yeah, I'll just give it.
Yeah,
I'll say one teachers.
That's actually one of the good
reasons I like managing this stuff.
I don't have to, not that I really
bought shirts that much anyway,
but I have a bunch of shirts. No
plus maybe my daughters too. Yeah.
Perfect. We're good. Yep. Good to go.
Everybody's good to go. Are they regular?
Are these the same design or is it
something new? It's there. Yeah.
They're more or less the same,
but they're,
they're basically the wounds
version of what we got it.
I started with a
discipline equals freedom.
I might just do one for
women because let's face it,
we all get get after it in pretty much
the same way except for every once in a
while.
Women get after it in a different way
every once in a while so it might be worth
it to give them a little
something different and special.
Just my opinion, I don't.
Awesome. All right, there you go.
That's always the support.
Support that podcast and with
that question number one,
I a marine corps vet only four years
and I recently hired another marine.
He had a great reputation and a
lot of experience as NCO leader,
gunny sergeant,
but he's not doing well in our company.
He only seems to lead through
fear. Slash. Authority.
It isn't working cause high standards,
which I like,
but he's not gaining the respect of
his team or the rest of the company.
What's going on and how can I fix it?
This is kind of a classic
case and unfortunately it's
an unfortunate case too.
And what we have here is an example of a
guy that's probably pretty charismatic.
He's probably pretty aggressive.
He's probably pretty loud.
He's probably pretty authoritative.
He's probably pretty smart.
He's probably physically impressive.
In other words,
he's probably got a lot of natural good
leadership traits and I surmise in a
situation like this,
that is the type of person that took the
basics of what the military taught him
and utilized it to lead.
And so what he did was he
used imposed discipline.
That's what guy used on him
and that's what he used.
So it's the things that we just
talked about, it's intimidation.
It's the whole thing with maneuver
warfare versus attrition warfare that the
military still teaches,
unfortunately,
that the job of leaders is to obey orders
and ensure orders are obeyed. Okay.
That's, that's what the military,
unfortunately in some cases,
teachers and you can go through your
career and that's what you can kind of
learn.
Or you can have some good leadership
inside the military that teaches you the
better way,
the way to actually lead.
And so,
but if you're,
if you're raised that the way that your
job as a leader is to obey orders and to
ensure that orders are obeyed. If
that's your job, how do you do that?
Will you do it through blunt force trauma?
That's how you do it.
And as I've said before,
that does work for a time period.
It does get the job done.
It's micromanagement and fortunately
or unfortunately in the military,
you've got people that rapidly
cycle through leadership positions.
And so it's not like you are permanently
in charge of the same group of people.
So you can kind of get away
with it because you do a
workup and it don't work of
a stressful,
and then you go on deployment to 20 it's
only six months long and by the time
you're done, everybody hates you, but it's
okay, you're moving onto your next job.
And so that's how people survive.
And what really hurts about this is
because they survive that leadership
position, it actually reinforces
that type of leadership behavior,
which is not good.
But what they do is if,
if let's say you do it,
it just an American kind of mindset of,
hey, if some is good, more is better.
And so they take this,
this attitude and they become more,
more aggressive.
They impose more discipline,
they raise the standards to ridiculous
level where it's no longer even sensible.
Yeah.
Where things just become
stupid like we used to say.
So I don't know why they called us,
but in the military they called a pushup
position, the front leaning rest. Sure.
Front leaning rest. I
don't know why, but I,
and then they also use the
term forward leaning, meaning,
Hey, we want to be ahead.
We want to be ready, ready,
prepared. And I used to say,
let's not be so far forward leaning
that were in the leaning rest.
Meaning that we're leaning so far
forward that we're wasting our energy and
getting tired and sore. At a certain
point it can become stupid thing.
An example of this would be like, um,
a uniform inspections. Like, okay,
you got to have a square to a uniform.
You know,
you got to be able to break out uniform,
look sharp.
Well if you do that every day,
you're wasting time because it's
not the most important thing. It,
it does have a level of importance
somewhere on the hierarchy of important
things, not real high,
but there's some people,
if you're a strict military
disciplinarian, you might think,
I need to have uniform instruction every
single day cause my guys are going to
look the best.
And so you've got a bunch of guys that
not only are they wasting time prepping
their uniform and paying
for them a uniform get dry
cleaned and they're actually
using their uniform is so much their
dress uniforms so much that they're
providing wear and tear on it. And
so it's just, it's just stupid.
It doesn't make any sense.
So that's,
that's what they do. They, these
leaders that have been raised like that,
they start to do it even more.
And it just,
it defeats its own purpose in most
important is that these leaders start to
stifle free fought from
their subordinates.
Okay.
And eventually,
and this is even more critical,
eventually they begin to stifle
free thought from their own brain.
And that's likely what happened
in a situation like this.
And you know,
you've got a guy that again was raised
in this attitude and he took that
attitude and he amplified that attitude
and that is how he was successful.
And he amplified it even more.
And he ends up,
now he breaks out of the Marine Corps.
Well now it's not just
a six month appointment.
You got to lead people for
years and years and years.
And you've got to go from
different various projects
and all these personalities.
And, and it's a more sensitive environment
because it's in the civilian sector in
lives aren't necessarily,
it's steak.
And so what do you need to do?
Okay,
what,
what you need him to see.
So now I'm talking to the leader
that asked this question, what,
what can you do to help?
Well,
what you need that former marine
gunnery sergeant to do. What
you need him to see is that
the next level of leadership,
the next progression along the spectrum
of leadership is not more of all that.
It's actually less.
It's not more imposed discipline
on your troops. It's actually less.
It's the troops having free thought
and self discipline and it is not you
leading more.
It is actually you leading less.
Eat is not you taking more ownership
is you taking less ownership and your
troops taking more ownership.
It is him giving guidance,
giving commander's intent
and then stepping back,
it is him not being the focus because a
lot of times when you're in a leadership
position that can be any ego feeder
and all of a sudden you want to be the
center of attention.
You want to be in the spotlight,
but you don't want to be that.
You want to be less of that and it,
and I'm telling you so
that's what you gotta do.
You gotta open his eyes to what the
next level of leadership looks like.
He's never had that open for him.
And I'm going to tell you right now,
it's going to be hard to get them there
because there's a good chance that he's
a hard person to coach because he's been
successful with the techniques that he
learned and he has experience and he's,
and that,
that experience has strengthened his
resolve and his belief in his leadership
technique. It's, it's,
it's a tough situation.
So you're likely going to have
to take an indirect approach.
And so for instance,
here's a good one. Hey,
I was wondering, you know who, who's going
to take your place when it's, you know,
when it's time for promotion, who
you grooming to fill your shoes? Hmm.
Cause guess what? He's
not grooming anybody. Hmm.
Or you ask him how much time he's spending
looking up and out at what's going on
in the strategic as opposed to down
and Ian that his own little element.
Yeah.
And the other thing that you could do
is assign him some higher level projects
that actually pull him out
of the micromanagement weeds
and maybe even put him on projects
with people that don't micromanage.
Hmm. And and good leaders
that lead in a good way,
put him on some kind of project with
them so he can see what that looks like.
Okay.
And obviously these are just some
suggestions of approaches because you're
probably going to have to,
you'll,
you'll have to adapt those and
figure out exactly how to walk him
to the end state,
which the end state,
the commander's intent from me is
you want to teach him what the next,
what the next level,
the next advancement of leadership skill
for him is and it's something that's
the opposite of what he learned.
So
good challenge. Yeah. Yeah. That,
that,
that leading from authority
thing and fear and authority.
It's almost like it's so black and
white where when someone does that,
it's so clear.
It's very clear and it's very addictive
person because there's immediate
gratification. I told you to do it
and so they do it and then OKC worked,
kind of takes less work to a
lot of the time keep us work.
You don't have to invest in relationships,
you don't have to invest in,
in indirect approaches on things.
Of course it takes less work. It's,
it's real simple. You know, you can kind
of give into your temper sometimes too.
Yeah. You're temper is a little
bit of a tool with that kind of,
the problem is over time these,
that type of leadership doesn't work.
You want to be with the beloved
captain who never lost his temper,
who never yelled at his men and yet who
would follow him into the fires of hell.
Yup.
Next question.
If you had a leader at work he did not
respect and know is ineffective and
you've communicated that Tim,
yet when they see you,
they tried to shake your hand,
how would you react and how would
you deny their handshake offering?
Appreciate the feedback. So,
um, okay. This is just off the,
off the mark. I hope people realize
that this is, no, it's okay. I mean,
I understand the reason I put this in
there just because this is what we talked
about earlier where you think,
man, I'm holding the line and I'm,
I'm holding the line and this is my
expectations of a leader and you don't fit
it. The song went to number one,
I'm gonna tell you number two,
if you're trying to shake my hand,
you're not getting it. Right, right.
So that's what we call an adversarial
relationship and it is not what we want.
How,
let me ask you this.
How is this going to help your cause to
have an error adversarial relationship
with your boss?
How does it help your cost?
Is he going to listen to you more or less?
Is he going to support you more or less?
Will he give you what
you want more or less?
Which one you won't shake his hand
and you think he's going to
support you in any way? No.
And furthermore,
is he,
if you have an adversarial
relationship with your boss,
is he more likely to promote you into
position where you can have more control
over decisions for the team
and for your own future?
What do you think the answer to that is?
Negative.
All those answers are obvious.
This
whole concept is wrong.
Our job is to build a relationship with
our boss and honestly with everyone else
for that matter.
That's what we're trying to do straight
up disrespecting the boss or again,
anyone is not going to help our cause.
It's going to hurt it.
Now,
this doesn't mean that we're kissing ass.
This doesn't mean that we're full being,
it doesn't mean that we're weak.
This is the,
this is the,
this is the challenge for me to convince
people that want to be strong leaders,
that this doesn't mean that you are
weak and actually takes more strength to
control your emotions. It takes more
strength to remain professional.
It takes more strength to focus on the
long term win and not the short term
frustration.
It takes more strength to keep your ego
in check and I would say that this whole
question is a good is a,
is an indicator to me.
I might need to check my own ego.
Okay. Am I critical of my boss?
Am I critical because of my boss?
Because I'm a little bit jealous.
Is that possible?
Am I critical of my boss because I think
I deserve the job more than they do.
Do I think that my boss got lucky or he,
he's a brown noser or
he's favored some way.
That's why he got it and I'm going to
be bitter about it and therefore I'm not
going to respect him. All
those right there, ego talking,
right full on ego talking.
So you got to put the ego in check.
You got to support the boss and
you got to support the team,
then that's the best way to support
the Boston support the team.
And the obvious caveat to this is if the
boss is doing something that's illegal
or immoral or unethical, then
fine. Yeah, of course. Absolutely.
You can call them out,
you can deny his handshake,
you can report them up the chain
of command or to the authorities.
Because if you're part of what
he's doing and you know it,
then you're complicit in the activities.
So you're at risk anyways
and it's the right thing to do. So
obviously in those cases, yeah, you,
you can hold your ground.
But barring those extreme circumstances,
what you wanna do with your bosses,
build the relationship. And again,
it's not just your boss, it's your peers.
It's your chain of command up and down.
You want to build those relationships
instead of breaking them.
Yeah.
Yeah. It seems, it's so funny, not funny,
but it's interesting how when you
lay it out, and I'm sure a lot,
maybe even when he's listening to this,
just hearing this question out
loud, it seems obvious, you know,
but really you're trying to think about
yourself in this situation where yeah,
you don't like this guy and maybe said
some stuff to offend you even and you
don't respect them obviously.
So yeah.
Like you don't want to
shake this guy's hand,
like how you feel is a lot of times
what dictates your behavior, you know,
towards people and just otherwise.
Um, so when you're in the situation,
this is kind of like, it's
so hard to be like, yeah,
I don't respect his whole methods.
I don't like any of this stuff.
He's going to come shake my hand.
It's so hard to be like, sure. And,
and do what you're talking about.
It can be put your ego in check,
put your emotions in check, put your
attitude in check and just go, hey boss,
how's it going today? Yup,
everything's going good here. Yeah,
so I appreciate the support you've been
given us. There's one decision you made.
I was kinda wondering about.
I'd love to give love to pick your
brain on and some point. Oh really?
Whereas if I just go, I don't want
to shake your hand. I hate you.
I basically disrespect you and
I hate you and what you do,
decision you made over here was wrong.
Is he going to listen to me?
There's no chance.
There's no chance you're going to wait.
You're gonna lose the argument. Me,
when I go in there and I say, hey boss,
how's it going? Yes.
Yeah, no problem. Hey, I,
one thing I wanted to pick your brain
about, this decision you made over here,
is he going to listen to me? You've got
a better chance. Still might say no,
but guess what? I'm fighting along war.
I'm gonna outlast him out. Work them.
I'm going to out maneuver him. My boss
is going to do what I'm wanting to do.
I know him. Yeah. You got to keep that
in mind, man, because when you're in it,
when you lose that little better
cause really that's what it is.
When you're shaking your hand and
you're like in your head, you're like,
I hate you.
I don't want to shake your hand.
Freaking get your hand out of my feet.
Your whole existence of your hand,
front of my face is an insult. That's
what you're thinking. So if you shake it,
you lost that battle and
that's bad right there for you.
That's what it feels bad.
It's, it's, it's very,
very immature when it,
it just feels right at the,
at the time. But if you let
your emotions get all crazy,
if you're not being strategic,
that's everything. Not
Thinking about winning. Yeah,
and by no means they might say playing
the game correctly, but the point is,
I understand that you feel as good as
when you say it out loud, it's like,
oh my gosh, it's so clear. Almost
he doesn't. He know what you, you,
you just indicated to me something
very obvious is that over time,
you know over time you get to the, okay,
you go for a hard workout and you get to,
you look forward to the feeling afterwards
of debt. Yeah, I did this hard workout.
There's endorphins or whatever.
I'm going to tell you at some point I
developed some sort of attitude where when
I do, when I control myself and
I make a good strategic move,
if he's just as good, it feels way
better than the short term. Aw Man.
I really told him no, no. Wrong
answer. You lost, you won the battle.
Lost the war idiot. That's what I
feel like if I make that mistake.
That's absolutely correct.
Don't leave you conditioned
yourself to the whole process.
You know,
cause he probably went
through it a few times,
tasted the fruits of winning the law
and so it's just with experience that
exactly right. Exactly right. So,
and there's ways you can
kind of do that to yourself.
Like I do if like even if you haven't,
like ultimately when,
when you boil kind of your whole way of
thinking down when you do have an ego
that you think is like a functional ego,
but use that ego to win the long words.
So let's kind of like what I did with
getting mad. It's like no one can like my,
like no one's going to tell me I have
low self esteem because really, you know,
angry, angry shoes is usually
because of low self esteem.
So in this case you could be like,
hey,
if you ever facilitate that adversarial
relationship where you don't shake his
hand or you're like, you want to, as he
said, you've communicated that to him.
You have a leader that you don't respect
and you know as an effective and you
told them, okay, so keep that.
When you say stuff like that,
consider that as like your weakness.
Like just tell yourself that whether
it is or they say that's your weakness,
but forgetting the long war and for and
for showing your cards that showing your
credit. Yes. Yeah. Just, it's this little
internal thing you'd tell yourself.
And then just like how you were
saying where you feel dumb,
you give your ego can't handle that,
can handle all that.
Then I'll go back to my point that I said,
this doesn't mean you're weak.
It means that you are winning.
Yeah.
But flip it around as far as what
you'd tell yourself. Like he, you know,
it feels we to lose a small
battle. I understand, but
flip it around and say, hey,
you know, if you win it at the expense
of the long, that means you're weak.
Say that to yourself and it'll get
easier. You know, you're rushing yourself.
If you lose the long term battle,
you're even more week. Yes.
That's the big weakness.
Weakness.
All right,
next question for the podcast.
What would ajiaco school for boys
and girls, eight to 16 years old,
this should be interesting. What would
that look like? Schedule Subjects,
physical education.
Sure.
So first of all,
I would love to do this and it's,
you're seeing one day I w I may do
this lord of the flies. Yes. Um, uh,
I, I actually really do relate
to kids for some reason.
And I think a school,
I think as I think I could develop
a school that would be awesome and
outstanding and would
produce really stable,
strong,
mentally capable
children for the world. So, and so,
I was so happy when I saw this question
and I've actually looked and I've
actually, I've actually pondered the
ideas of, you know, buying a house,
buying a piece of property,
you know,
what it would cost maybe getting some
investors together that we're going to
build a scar. I mean, I've literally,
I've actually looked for property,
which is something I do all the time, but
I've looked for property and said, okay,
this probably work. So, uh, like, uh,
like almost like an extension school,
like in the little [inaudible] academy,
like a school that you go to, right.
And you and we, we, what we
could probably do is do like a,
instead of a, hey, you're gonna go
here from sixth grade to graduation,
you go for like one year,
you go one year here you go
back to your regular school,
after you've been in
the school for a year,
three to go back to your regular school,
you're going to totally dominate.
You're going to be number one.
You're going to learn so much more.
It's just going to be awesome.
So we will need to bring,
we wouldn't need to bring these young,
these,
these children into the school for,
for the entire time because you know,
you could go out,
back out into the regular
world and overlay what you
learned at the academy and
you would just dominate. And so, um, yeah,
maybe I'll end up doing that
someday and the schedule,
I mean I think I didn't
spend that much time on it.
It doesn't really even take
that much time to figure out,
cause you know what we're doing.
We're waking up very early in the morning.
We're doing a hardcore PT,
some kind of sports variety of sports.
Guess what, we're playing every sport,
you know, baseball, basketball, swimming,
football, soccer, wrestling,
judo, boxing at we're new,
a little bit of everything
that's going to happen really.
I mean obviously we're getting up at four
30. We are up before the sun gets up.
I mean that's the way it is.
And then we get the knowledge.
So we'd go into the classrooms,
the classrooms,
W I w I would get instructors that will
full on engaged in what they're doing
just in the game that love their subject
and that can relate it to the world.
And most important,
cause I think this is what's lacking
sometime most important through all the
different knowledge courses.
So all the basic knowledge there would
be a common thread that connects them all
together because that's what I
think people are missing that a lot.
I think we miss that, that
underlying theme of, uh,
through our educational system.
But I think when you connect everything,
they're more powerful. Like when you
connect math to science, to history,
to English,
to foreign language,
and you connect those to
art and music and you can,
there's some there cause they're all
those things. If you look at history,
all of those things are connected.
They're all connected,
but we don't make the connections
and when you don't connect things,
they're weaker.
So I would,
I would force or I wouldn't mean
you wouldn't have to force it.
You don't have to force it.
I would,
I would foster that thread through
everything so that everything made sense,
you know, in a big picture. And
that way when you get granular,
you're tying it into this overlying
theme of civilization and the movement of
the way things go through civilization.
Now I'll tell you another piece of this.
You would learn vocational skills at my
school 100% you would learn carpentry,
you would learn how to do electrical
wiring, you would learn plumbing,
you would learn automotive
and motor repair.
You would learn all those things and
guess what are you going to take those
courses? Like I said this, this court,
this school would probably only be a year
long. That's fine because guess what?
You know how long it takes to learn
basic carpentry. Not Real Long.
Are you gonna be a skilled carpenter?
No,
but I'm not looking to
build skilled carpenters.
Are you going to be ready
to rewire a giant building?
A commercial building? No.
But could you rewire a house?
Likely it doesn't take that much time to
learn that. You won't be skilled at it,
but you will have the knowledge.
Same thing with plumbing and like I said,
the automotive,
so I,
so you would learn those vocational
skills because we have people in America
right now that don't know any of
that stuff. And that's jacked up.
Yeah.
Even like when I was young,
my dad used to make us change our own oil
there. Now you can, you can go anywhere.
It takes thinking whatever's
50 minutes, but he's like, Nah,
you change your own oil. You got to
know what to do with the oil. You know,
there's this little process.
You can't just be rolling around and
change flat tire. Even though I have AAA,
I don't,
I don't culture blade for flat tire
because Seitan hadn't got a flat tire in
long time.
I got a flat tire one day and actually
recently I've been getting kind of fun
nonetheless. But I change them every
time because when I first got it,
after not having a flat tire
for awhile, I thought, Oh man,
do I even remember how to do this? Of
course I did. I remember how to do it.
It's not that hard, just like you said.
So there are people who don't know,
they get a flat tire and they're, they're,
they're lost, they're lost. And they,
yeah, they don't have, they have AAA
or whatever. Sure. They get saved.
What if they can do with them themselves?
You know?
So at my school you would learn those
vocational skills and then on top of that
you'd learn basic survival skills,
little hunting or fishing,
little gardening and planting
and how to grow things,
grow food and your basics,
water, fire and shelter.
You'd learn those. So you'd be able to
survive in any environment, any situation,
obviously with all those survival skills.
And the vocational skills and even
the classroom knowledge skills there
B, a, a
system of team building where you're going
to be doing things together as a team,
not only for your classes but also
cleaning the place, working together.
And even that's what they do. And in
military boot camps, all you do is clean.
They turned cleaning into like a team
building exercise. So we would do that.
Uh,
people would be in simple uniforms,
you know, nothing too fancy.
Obviously the nighttime would be the
study of the martial arts and you would
learn the basics of Jujitsu,
boxing,
Muay Thai and wrestling.
And that's what my school would be like.
And there'd be some real discipline there
and there would be real achievement.
And I think that anybody that spent one
year in that school right there would
have
a infinitely greater chance
of success and domination
in whatever they feel
they chose to go into.
And when they went back to their school,
to their regular school,
you, it's funny at first, at
first thought when you're calm,
kind of picturing this stuff or whatever.
And I'm sure I'm not the only one
listening to this where you'd be like,
oh shoot, that product, that's
a hardcore school, you know,
they gotta be ready to get and now
you need, now you want to go. Well,
when you think about it, it probably
wouldn't be that hardcore. In fact,
it probably be kind of fun given
your approach to, you know,
teaching or in leading and
stuff like that because man,
I remember when I f it was
like when I first met you,
I met you and you don't remember
when I first met you, but um,
so I kind of knew you were whatever it,
a little bit,
this is back at the boxing club and you
came in as a first time I saw your kids
toward like Thor and I think one of his
sisters, I forget, I don't know which one,
I forget. Oh, they were just little kids
and you had brought them or whatever.
And they come in the door and
they just start running around.
Like this is a big playground.
Right, right, right. Yeah.
Hitting the bags and doing all this stuff.
Right.
And then you had this look on your face,
Kinda like you see,
it's almost like you had
control of the situation,
but you're just going to let
them be them kind of thing.
And I remember just kind of
kind of looking at it like,
oh this is interesting.
I'd never seen Jocko and his
kids, you know, so let me,
so I was kind of just watching.
So decentralized command in
a manner of speaking. Yeah.
So just to start to kind of
going on and I think you're,
you might even been teaching,
I don't know, you were
involved in some way and um,
they got loud real quick and it kind
of was like, for lack of a better term,
kind of distracting and you like kind of
stop what you're doing. You were like,
you could stop that. Like real,
real mean. And then I was like,
let me see like how they react, you
know, I look and then they stop.
They look at you like just, just for
maybe almost two seconds. They look,
he look at each other like that and they
just start laughing and they keep going.
You kind of started laughing at the
same time. I was like, oh, I see.
Like you're probably strict,
but it's not that they're kids,
they're doing kid stuff. We want,
they're not breaking nothing. Yeah.
So it was like, it's almost like they
knew and then they knew beyond that,
you know, like they knew what was
ultimately up. That was interesting. Well,
who knows, maybe we can put this
school together at some point.
I know there's a lot of people that
would love to send their kids to a school
like this on every,
and I would obviously I
send all my kids to school
like this tomorrow if it existed.
Yeah. One Year of the academy.
That's what it's called, the academy.
I think it would have to be. Yep.
A big part of it.
Yeah.
And I'm sure this would pro,
and I'm sure there's would be,
would be implemented in the whole system
is how the teachers and instructors are
treated. For sure. You know like,
because I think that's a lot of the time
anyway. Like one of the many issues,
you know when they,
when issues come up in education,
it's like how are the teachers
regarded? Yeah. That situation.
Yeah man. Yeah. Good. Sign me
up. Okay. Okay. Next question.
I'm about to accept a position across
the country after changing the IT field I
work in,
I've just been accepted from my first
job and in this type of position with the
amount of responsibility
I'll have and I'm not,
or I'm having some issues and some heavy
hesitations on if I'll be good enough.
Have you ever been in a position before
where you tried to bite off more than
you can chew professionally?
How do you approach it and is there ever
a time where you think it's best to bow
out and quit? And if so, how
do you know when that point is?
So,
uh,
actually most people get hired into
leadership positions they haven't been in
before. The seal teams is all
about that. You get promoted,
you do that leadership job in just
as you're getting the hang of it,
you get promoted again.
So there's nothing abnormal about
feeling that you aren't quite ready for a
leadership position.
And the reason that some people fail
when they get to these positions that
they're not ready for is because they're
nervous that they're going to show that.
And so they tried to hide it.
They're afraid to ask questions,
they're afraid to say they don't know.
So they end up looking scared and stupid.
Hmm.
Which equates to looking in competent.
And I mean even just with the beloved
captain, Neat, they actually kicked off.
There's a reason this guy included
those statements in there that he asked
questions and asked for guidance
and admitted his mistakes.
There's a reason that he was beloved.
That is one of the reasons.
Okay.
And so, so,
so that's what you gotta
do is be okay with it.
Don't try and hide it now to bow
out and quit. I have not done that,
but there's no reason to because if
I don't know how to do something,
I have no problem asking for help.
Up and down the chain of command,
up and down the chain of command.
Nothing wrong with that.
And I've said this before,
that what, what you're feeling.
Okay.
Um,
person that asked this question,
what you're feeling that you weren't
good enough and that you don't want
to blow it. Those are actually
signs of humility and it's okay.
Those are good.
I've felt those feelings my whole career
and I still feel I'm now and when I was
in the seal teams I would over prepare
for things and it wasn't because I
thought I was going to dominate it was
cause I thought I was going to fall short
it even I was telling you
I prepared for the podcast all yesterday.
I thought I was good.
Literally had printed out my notes,
woke up this morning,
worked out and I was like, no, I'm not
ready. I over prepare for this. Why?
Because in my mind I'm feeling that I'm
going to blow it and I don't like that.
The thing, it's like a for real
thing, it's called imposter syndrome.
You've heard of that? No, it's this
and I think, you know what? I think,
I think everyone has it in whether
it's a teeny tiny bit or a lot.
It's where it's basically you feel this,
you feel like I'm really like on the
inside, like I'm really not this good.
You can be like champion of the world
and on the inside you're like this just a
matter of time before they find
me out. You know, I, I don't know.
I don't deserve to be here.
Whatever that I wish more people would
have that because there's a lot of people
that I know that have been in leadership
positions that feel that they have the
divine right to be there.
A lot of times they'll have it,
they'll behave in that.
Oh they absolutely you're saying you do.
That's why they fail.
That's crazy.
So rehash as always,
bottom line,
be humble.
Study and learn what you can ask
questions and if you don't know something,
admit it.
Now I had to make this note,
and I'm cautious to even say this,
but I do have to say it.
Asking questions doesn't just mean putting
your ignorance on clear display all
the time. Okay. When you ask questions,
make sure you are asking thoughtful,
meaningful questions.
In fact,
if you can find out the
answer on your own, do that.
If it's something that you can refer back
to and you can look up and you can go
back and you can check out the org chart,
you can see where that department is
or you can find out who's running that
project without having to
ask that question. Do that.
Because
contrary to popular belief,
there actually is in fact such a thing
as a stupid question and you can get away
with it sometimes. So you don't
need to be hyper paranoid about it,
but you also,
part of leadership is confidence and uh,
up and down.
So you got to have some confidence and
you people have to have some confidence
in you. And if, if you don't know anything
and you can't figure it out for,
you can't figure out some
portions of that on your own.
That's not a good sign because I just
expect you're gonna be in charge of me.
Well that you can look that up.
You didn't,
you didn't review this before you came
in here. I know you don't know my job,
but you should at least know what
the requirements of my job are. You,
she didn't at least know what the outcomes
at a strategic level of my job are.
Right? You see what I'm
saying? There's a difference.
So you don't have to go in there and be,
um,
overly humble.
You don't have to go in there
and be overtly blank, uh, uh,
wide open with what you,
with what you don't know.
Because again, I was cautious to make
this note because this doesn't, I w I,
you should feel comfortable enough
saying, hey, I don't know how to do this.
Or Hey, can you explain that
the way that works to me?
Can you explain what this project,
you know, what this project entails.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if you go into a room
and you accidentally ask a
question of something that
everybody legitimately should know,
you're going to look stupid. Right?
That's a mistake. That's a
mistake. And so don't do that.
It's okay. Be Humble, ask questions.
But ask thoughtful questions,
meaningful questions that you
don't know because it's brewed,
it would be pretty difficult for you
to know the answer yet. It's the,
I mean it kind of seems obvious when you
say it out loud where you're not going
to know everything. No,
so that makes sense.
But you've got to know something's
gotta be there for a reason.
You can't be like, hey, I don't know
nothing. I shouldn't be hearing it.
And that's another thing from the beloved
captain or he says for a few days he
didn't do anything. Guess what?
If you can observe for a few days,
you're probably going to answer a bunch
of questions just for observation and
taking notes and getting back and maybe
conferring with your trusted agent or
you're a senior enlisted guy or you're,
you're a superintendent.
You can confer directly
with them and keep that,
build that relationship while
you're guard garnering information.
Yeah, don't be that guy trying
not to. It's true. Try not to
Jocko,
how do I take ownership of mixed messages
to the people under me from the other
leaders in my group? Pretty
straightforward question. I like it.
Well first of all,
you have to address this straight up
with the other leaders in your group
because if you aren't
aligned as a leadership team,
this is going to hurt the cause.
It is absolutely going to hurt the cross.
This is critical and
it's going to be hard.
And there are some things in your group
that people do not agree on and that is
why they are undermining the messaging
or why they're giving out different
messaging because they
don't agree with it.
They don't have the courage
to stand up and say, Hey,
I don't agree with this right here,
so let's do it a different way.
Here's my thoughts. They don't have the
courage to that. So what do they do?
They just sit back and then when
it comes time to put out the word,
they put up the mixed messages and it's,
it's a bad situation and you
actually have to lead here.
That's what you have to do.
Any,
it shouldn't actually be that hard because
what you're asking for is something
that anybody can tell is
important. So, you know, you said,
do you say to your leadership
team, you go, hey guys,
our message to the troops needs to
be aligned. And right now it isn't.
We need to fix that.
Is there anyone on your leadership
team's going to disagree with that? No,
they won't. That's not what
they disagree with. They,
everybody knows that the leadership
team has to have an aligned message.
They have to be on the
same sheet of music.
And that's what you need
to do. And, and again,
it's going to be a hard conversation.
It's going to bring out that statement
should bring out the conversation of what
people don't agree on and why
they're sending ms messages. Now,
if you,
if you cannot get them aligned,
it is a serious problem.
But if you can't,
the best thing you can do is mitigate,
mitigate that to your team by
becoming the trusted voice.
So, so with your team, you want
to become the trusted voice.
Now you did this doesn't mean they're
going to go on undermine your other
leaders. It's a, I'll echo came in here.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
No, no, no, no, no, no. That's
not what I'm talking about.
I'm never almost never talking about
undermining another leader or a leadership
team. What I'm going to do though is
I'm going to translate them and say,
hey guys, our job on this, I Know Echo
said that. Here's our job. Here's,
here's what our focus needs to be.
Here's the way this translates for us,
so I'm not disparaging you and
I'm not even disagreeing with you.
I'm simply honing the message for my team.
Now you still, even when you do that,
you're mitigating that
as much as possible.
You still have to maintain the critical
goal of getting your leadership team
aligned and one other little tool to
help make that happen is to present their
words back to them and you said,
you know what?
I wrote down what you said to the team
this morning and I just wanted to go
through that with you and break it down
a little bit and and then go through it
line by line and have the
hard conversations and
make the tough decisions.
You've got to make the tough decisions
and also give a little seed some points,
right?
Be Flexible but unify,
unify the message. And there's a
worse, not even a worst case scenario,
but there are scenarios where echo and
I cannot agree on the message and we got
to go up the chain of command.
Now, I would never want to do that.
I would never ever want to say to my boss,
Hey,
echo and I can agree you need to
make the decision for us. To me,
that's a total failure.
It's a failure in my leadership that I
can't get us on the same sheet of music.
So I don't, I can't even think
of any time that I ever did that.
Went to my boss and said, hey
boss, I can't we, you know,
I can't come to come to a conclusion here
with the other task in new commanders
or I can't come to a conclusion with
the other platoon commanders or I can't
come come to conclusion with the my
squad about how we should do this.
I've never done that. So you should be
able to, if you're right, you'll win.
The argument and if you're
wrong then you change your mind.
So it's not that it's not like this
ultimate, not like I'm saying I'm great.
I'm just saying if you're right,
then you'll win the argument and if
you're wrong then you'll change your mind.
So it's not that hard.
So that's what happens.
Needs to happen here
with the leadership team.
We've got to find out who's right and
people that are right need to convince the
people that are wrong. Now
you need to check your ego.
Obviously across the board,
every t everybody on the team's got to
check the Ricoh cause a lot of people
will be holding onto their idea because
it's their idea and they loved their idea
because there's egotistical
and that's how I would deal with mixed
messages coming down the chain of
command.
I'm going to go ahead and just say it.
That could have been one of the best
lines I've ever heard. If you're right,
you win the argument. If you're wrong,
you'll change your mind. That's a good,
that's a good word. You just make that
up. I didn't just make it up. I mean,
I guess it's something that
I've known but right. Yeah.
That's what makes it so good. Cause
you kind of, it kind of seems like,
Oh yeah you don't. Right.
But that's never the case.
But if you're being on the up and up,
there it is right there.
Yeah.
There you go. Echo likes that one.
No, we've got time for about one more.
I don't see why not.
Jocko,
you often talk about being on the path.
What path is that and where does it lead?
Ah,
yes,
the path.
Well I can tell you what path I'm on
and what path I strive to stay on.
And that is the war path.
That's the path I'm on
the war path.
A path of war.
Cause to me warpath means
moving toward a battle,
a fight towards [inaudible].
Yeah.
In that is what I am doing.
And that's what I've always been doing.
Whether it was the actual war
against our nation's enemies
or the war
against my own weaknesses.
That is what I am doing.
Preparing
and,
and sharpening my sword and honing my
skills and maintaining the unmitigated
daily discipline in all things.
And the war path is just that.
It's a path.
It's a root.
It leads somewhere.
And so you ask, okay,
then where does it lead?
And yes, yes, it,
it can lead to war.
And that's fine.
In fact,
I am waiting
and I am ready
because the war path is
a war against weakness.
And so it leads to strength.
It's a war against ignorance.
And so it leads to knowledge
eats a war against confusion.
And so it delivers
understanding
and the path,
the war path leads to
control and leads to
ownership of your life.
And that to me is the war path,
the path of fire and adversity,
the path of blood and
sweat and of suffering.
The warpath is the preeminent
path of discipline,
which is why
it leads to freedom.
And beyond that,
in the end,
the war path,
it leads
to peace.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So thanks to everyone out there for
taking the time to listen to this,
this,
this little podcast we put together.
And if you like it,
then you want to support it.
Echo. Nah, do they do that?
If you're in the mood,
if you worked out,
I know you heard this before,
but if you work out and you want
supplements that actually work because the
supplement industry,
and you probably know this bro,
they can put whatever they want and
there's no regulation. Yeah, you can,
I don't know if it was a documentary.
It's something like that where a guy
just put chalk, that's all it was.
Chalk and there he was like, hey
look, protein powder, sell it.
And either he found there was like,
there was no like regulation saying
he couldn't do it technically anyway.
Um, it's, it's a whole
long thing nonetheless.
If you want for real ones where
it's actually not a bad product id,
we could make protein powder that
you can use as chocolate bar.
So you could be chalking up and then
eating. Yeah. Good. No. Yeah, yeah.
I Dunno. Maybe you get on it to
make the protein powder chalkup
yeah, that's, that's a little bit
different from what else kind of sane.
But nonetheless,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash Jocko you can get 10% off their
supplements.
Anyway.
My point being with that story is that
their supplements are all like legit.
And you can even read about
it like the [inaudible] oil.
I said this before,
I feel like I said this before,
but you can see like how they harvest
them. They use like eco friendly boats.
Like it's like, it's basically
the ones who went to go votes.
Like the engines are like ecofriendly and
like, you know, like that kind of stuff.
Anyway, I was watching it. You can
get addicted on there. But um, yeah,
all legit warrior bars. I feel like we
haven't really talked about worrying.
I got asked by somebody on Twitter
the other day what, you know, hey,
my joints are hurting, which I take,
take her awhile. Yeah, that's it man.
Take her while. Yeah. I've been using
[inaudible] for a really long time.
I'm 44 years old.
I'm almost 45 years old actually.
And my joints are doing
solid and knock on wood. Um,
you know,
I had some joint pain in the past
and when I started taking Krill oil,
I'm talking 10, maybe
even longer years ago. Um,
the,
it's I,
I definitely attributed to helping
me and also also the glucosamine.
Yeah. So, and that's saying
a lot because you're big.
You're a big guy to third
if I'm not exactly flexible.
Yeah.
Flexible person.
And I do like,
I do heavy duty stuff. I
mean I'll get after it. Not,
not as much as I want to and not
as much as I should, but I tried,
I tried to, to work out
hard. I train Jujitsu,
I surf, I run, I sprint,
I just do all kinds of activities.
And before up until several years ago,
I was in the military,
I was in the seal teams and I was
running around doing all that crap for my
whole life.
And so yeah,
I would say order up some krill oil bro.
Just saying,
just doing Jujitsu alone, especially
as much as you do it, that alone,
old young, whatever, just
doing the end. You're like,
my joints are fine if you're in that
situation to buy that alone. Yeah. And,
and the Krill oil for sure.
And also I believe that
working out period is,
is very helpful in staying injury free
because I always work out and therefore
I'm always moving and therefore
my joints aren't getting rusty,
you know? Do both, do both.
You know, I do get injured,
you know, I had the finger injury, which
is a better net. Pretty good right now.
I had, um, I had my shoulder
got tweaked a little bit.
Yeah. But that's a situation that's
nice. Got me from rolling. Yeah.
And that's not the kind of, Hey, I should
have took more krill oil. It's not that,
it's like, it's like when you wake up
or when you, when you're like, Hey,
I'm going to go out. You start
working. You're like, Oh Dang,
I got to warm up some more. Some Marshall,
you know, and I take it, just Fyi,
I take three of the 500 milligram,
what are the capsules in the
morning and three at night?
That's a lot of thousand a day
yet. Dang. Well, hey, there
you go. Then do that then.
I mean, like I said, you're a big
tank that needs more pills anyway.
Yeah, it's good and firm on it. You know,
you're getting like the good, the good on.
Yeah. You know, it's not
kidding. The clean stuff,
mass manufactured, you know the
one from the corner store. Krill.
Yeah man, it's good. And you get 10% off,
which is honored grid on a
flash Jocko podcasts probably.
It's a, it's a win. Win, win.
Yeah. And speaking to port
it, supporting this podcast,
amazon.com click through,
it might be the best way.
I don't know if it's the best way I would
say it. It's another way. No other way,
which is very effective,
which has definitely
helped support the podcast.
Yeah. And it doesn't cost anything.
It's real easy to do. You just click.
Yeah, no, yeah, that's good. Yeah. The
key thing to that one is remembering it,
remembering to do it true too. And he's
like, yeah, trooper tool, we got that.
So go on the chrome extension.
Interpretable chrome extension.
If you haven't put that
on your browser and,
and you do want to support the
podcast through the Amazon situation,
put that on there. It's easy. It makes
it super easy, efficient, aggressive,
active and efficient,
not passing like your attitude.
You can support that way. And then, um,
obviously the po it subscribe
on Itunes and the Youtube,
which I'm putting more
videos on there starting to,
and it's going to pick up too.
I got some more content I'm going
to put up for sure. And then, um,
the Jocko store if you like shirts
and whatnot, if you like them,
get one of those and we
have women's coming out.
Is there anything else
you have coming out? Yeah,
it's a secret. Yeah. Okay.
Actually if you're signed up for the,
if you enlisted in the,
what is it that the insider check email
and find out what else is out there,
what else is coming, what
else is on the horizon? Yeah.
Cause we've had a lot of
people ask for this item. What?
Give me a hint.
Rash guards
[inaudible] rash guards are coming up,
don't do Jujitsu.
And they still wear rash guards for
like working out, working out or um,
or diving or, or Surf Surfing or
surfing originally for, yeah. Yeah.
I use the surfing rash guard a lot
of times for Jujitsu. But yeah,
the record's coming out and then if you,
if you're into the Geek,
you got some patches to, Oh,
you got the patches coming
out too. They're good, cool.
Basic the way we like them. But yeah.
Anyway, Jaclyn [inaudible] dot com that's,
you can see all this stuff
and um, yeah, if he, if,
if you want to be on the insider's list,
we don't,
I don't spam people were saying you
like stuff just for the sake of sending
stuff. I don't do that. In fact,
I kind of understand stuff. Yeah.
People don't want to be bothered if,
if you're going to send something,
make it be important.
Yeah.
At least something that I honestly think
that you'd be interested in. Yes. Yeah.
Honestly, I'm a put some
thought into that. So yeah,
there it is. That's the waste.
Now in the very,
very near future,
like I'm talking maybe a week
and it's by early September,
2016,
you will be able to order Jocko white tea
and you'd be able to order it from Amazon,
which is good to go.
And I got my first
batch in matter of fact,
I'm drinking a little bit of
that stuff. Right. And um,
it's, it definitely puts
you in the zone low place.
I like to call the assault zone. It gets,
gets you there. So look for it. This is,
this is,
you know,
if you heard that first podcast
with Tim Ferriss and he was like,
what is this adrenaline filled drink?
It was white tea and white tea
is not loaded with caffeine.
There's other stuff in there,
there's magic in there,
there's antioxidants in
there. It tastes good. And uh,
anyways, so that's common. You'd be
able to order it. We're kind of wonder,
I'm kind of wondering to see if people
want Jocko white tea. I think they do.
Yeah. And we will find out
shortly. I know I do. Yeah, it's,
that's an interesting
thing because you know,
like just kind of on the surface won't
be like, hey fuck what's Jocko into?
It's not like,
you know something crazy.
It's like something let's face
it sounds kind of delicate,
you know white well when you see the
can that it comes in, it's not delicate.
It's delicate.
It's weird cause I was trying to think
of where I discovered it and I actually
don't know. I actually can't remember
how, why drink it for the first time,
but when I started drinking I
was like, oh yeah, this stuff,
it feels good.
Especially when under stress or
there's a lack of sleep or um,
you need to be mentally sharp.
It's the deal.
But you can mix white tea with,
it'll mess up the taste.
But you mix Jocko white tea
with Alpha brain. I've done it.
I've done it. I've done it
here in the podcast. Yeah.
It doesn't mess up the taste.
It tastes good. Dang. All right.
We'll get the white tea. Is,
is a, it's not like this super
harsh taste. It's a supermarket.
It's a mild cause you can taste it.
You can kind of feel it to
length but heavy, he'd say,
I don't even know how to describe it.
It's just not an act.
It's not a heavy taste. Yeah, so you
can mix it with lot of stuff. Um,
and you can, like I said, you can
be able to get that on Amazon,
see a click through the,
get it on Amazon.
You can also go ahead and get by the
below book called extreme ownership when
you're there you recommend. Yup,
and you can get that anywhere.
Anywhere they sell books.
You can buy the hardcover.
He can buy the digital audio format,
which my brother Leif
Babin and I actually read.
You can get it for your people up and
down the chain of command, your friends,
family, whoever it is that you think
needs to get on board with the program,
get him a copy.
That's kind of a good initiator forum.
And also October 20th
and 21st in San Diego,
we are having the extreme ownership
muster that is also Leif Babin and myself.
We're going to be getting granular,
granular with the combat leadership
lessons that we learned on the battlefield
and how you apply those
lessons in your business
and in your life.
Now that event is going to be
extremely interactive. It's more not
going to be hiding behind the curtain.
We're going to be out front with
the troops. If you got questions,
we are going to answer them.
If you got something you need,
we're going to talk about it.
If you've got a problem,
we're going to come up with a solution.
I say we because it we were going to
work together. We're going to learn.
I can't wait to see how much
I'm going to learn with the,
the list of people that
are coming is awesome.
It every industry you could imagine every
level of leadership you can imagine.
It's just,
it's really going to be fired up and
laugh and I've been hammered out the
schedule and there's so much material
and so much good information and so much
good content. It's going to be awesome
and I cannot wait to kick it off.
Or do you just do part of the schedule?
Jujitsu is not on the schedule,
but what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to basically have a Jujitsu situation
happening at the gym. So the
event is Thursday, Friday,
so maybe it's going to be Wednesday night.
If people come in early,
maybe it's going to be Saturday.
If people want to stay or Sunday
people want to stay the weekend. So,
or just have them like where they're like,
you know, the welcome come to the gym.
You know,
like these are the things from the moment
I could just bring some mats to the
hotel and do some kind of a, but
now when they, then we got to,
now Jim is way better because
it's like that, you know,
one of the best people to
the gym. Yeah. So yeah,
if you want to get the Jujitsu together,
we are going to get the Jimmy and I
trained Jujitsu. I'm in San Diego,
I'm training, so we'll be in
San Diego. We will be training,
we might not be able to do it Thursday
night because it's a packed schedule. Um,
doesn't end until late at night,
but either Wednesday night or probably
probably once the monsters over cause
head heading into the monster.
I'm going to be like David.
Actually I think it would go. No, I
have an event earlier in the week,
so probably going to be
the weekend if you want.
If you want to get your Jujitsu on, stay
the weekend. Yeah. Home Sunday afternoon,
get a red eye flight back to
the east coast or whatever and,
or if you're out here,
just go home Sunday night.
And that's kind of um,
just muster. No mustard.
People come in and they're like, hey,
I want to come in that gym. Yeah,
but guys have comms getting Max. I
just, I just met him and his girlfriend,
his wife, I forget if they're married now,
but they came in and he was like, Hey,
um, you know, I just came in
and whatever. Um, so yeah,
people would just come in and they just
let him into, of course, you know? Yeah.
Also a look.
I know that the monster is expensive
and in this situation, guess what?
It costs money to put it on. It costs
money for the hotel room, the event,
the event room, the Food Dav
equipment, the security, the logistics,
all that stuff.
It costs money.
And the reason that we're investing in
it is because we want it to be the best.
We want it to be.
The best event that you have ever been to.
That's what I want.
That's all.
And but that does cost money.
And so if you can't afford to
come out to it, you know what,
I apologize the, but the podcast
is free. The book is 20 bucks.
Um,
get what you can out of that.
But if you can't afford to come out,
come on out because you being there is
going to make us all better because every
single person that I get so
many responses on Twitter,
I get so many stuff,
so much stuff through,
through the social media that
I'm learning from everyone here.
So anybody that can come
out and participate and ask
that question or give that
scenario or give that piece of input
is going to make us all better.
So come on out and get some.
And
as always,
if you want to continue this conversation,
you know where you can
find us all up on that.
Andrew Labs, Twitter,
Instagram, and that Facebook,
he Baja,
it's echo at Echo Charles
and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally
to you,
to those of you out there in the battle,
our military guys in Iraq and in Syria,
fighting against a truly evil,
an abhorrent enemy.
Okay.
Stay Sharp,
stay focused and be aggressive.
It'll keep you alive to
the police officers who are
suffering through hard times
right now, verbal and physical
attacks. I'm going to tell you,
take the high ground in both those cases.
Detach from that negativity and do
your job to the best of your ability.
Be Smart and stay safe.
And of course the firefighters
and emergency medical teams
that keep us safe,
keep us healthy and come
to us in our time of need.
You all stay vigilant and train hard.
Yeah.
And to the rest of you troopers out there
all over the world doing what you are
doing.
Make sure you do that thing with
every ounce of effort you got
and make sure you stay,
yeah.
Stay on the war path
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.
Okay.